ich rufe auf den einzelplan
ich rufe auf den einzelplan 14
bundes zu und da geht es um den
verteidigungsetat der so hoch ist wie
noch nie 50 4 milliarden euro sollen für
das jahr 2022
zur verfügung stehen das sind noch
einmal rund
3,5 milliarden euro mehr als im
vorherigen jahr und hinzu kommt ja noch
das sondervermögen in höhe von 100
milliarden euro weil es ein
sondervermögen test wird es ja nicht zum
haushalt gerechnet auch das war ja im
plenum schon häufig thema und dort ist
die debatte auch noch nicht ganz
abgeschlossen wobei sich union und die
ampel koalition ja zumindest auf die
geplante grundsatz änderung für dieses
sondervermögen geeinigt haben aber heute
morgen hat dann die union doch gesagt
dass sie inhaltlich ihn noch nicht
genügend zeit hatte um in die details zu
schauen um zu schauen welche
rüstungsprojekte damit finanziert werden
sollen für die union spricht jetzt ingo
gädechens cdu csu
kollegen in der gegenwärtig
schrecklichen situation des russischen
angriff gegen die ukraine diskutieren
wir hier und heute den verteidigungsetat
der bundesrepublik deutschland für das
laufende haushaltsjahr
mittlerweile befinden wir uns im
sechsten monat des jahres und es wird
höchste zeit dass dieser einzelplan der
in weiten teilen auch noch erkennbar die
handschrift der großen koalition trägt
verabschiedet wird die truppe braucht
dringend diesen etat damit ausrüstungs
vorhaben umgesetzt und damit neue
beschaffungsvorhaben beauftragt werden
können zwischen der ersten und der
jetzigen zweiten und dritten lesung des
haushalts liegen gut acht wochen und in
meiner damaligen rede habe ich ihnen
frau
bundesverteidigungsministerium frau
lamprecht hilfreiche tipps gegeben wie
man in diesem zugegebenermaßen
schwierigen ministerium das eine oder
andere fettnäpfchen umschiffen könnte
sie haben meine ratschläge leider nicht
angenommen und das hatte zur folge um in
ihrem sprachgebrauch zu bleiben dass sie
eine torte nach der anderen ins gesicht
bekommen haben
deshalb noch mal mein rat hören sie hin
und wieder auf menschen die
verteidigungspolitik schon etwas länger
und mit viel herzblut betreiben hier und
heute
geht es weniger um sie frau ministerin
sondern primär um den haushalt und dabei
waren für mich die vergangenen
beratungen durchaus bemerkenswert in den
zurückliegenden jahren vertrat die union
in diesem haus ziemlich einsam die
auffassung dass die bundeswehr chronisch
unterfinanziert ist erst mit dem
furchtbaren krieg in der ukraine hat es
auch bei anderen fraktionen und unseren
ehemaligen koalitionspartnern einen
wirksamen hallo wach ruf gegeben besser
spät als nie heißt es bekanntlich im
volksmund auf jeden fall eine positive
nachricht für unsere soldatinnen und
soldaten
auch wenn die
beratung in den bericht der stadt der
gesprächen im gewohnt kollegialer
atmosphäre
verliefen war ich beim genaueren
hinsehen an einstellen doch etwas
enttäuscht schon seit wochen müssen wir
ja leider zunehmend beklagen dass von
seiten der bundesregierung nicht das
umgesetzt wird was
oftmals
großartig großspurig angekündigt wird
nicht ohne grund titeln die nationalen
als auch die internationalen
medien deutschland ziert sich zaudert
zögert oder zerredet die dinge die
unendlichen verwirrungen beim thema
waffenlieferungen an die ukraine sind
leider ein mahnendes beispiel wie eine
regierung in zentralen fragen schon nach
einem halben jahr im amt jeden anspruch
auf eine wahrhaftige und verlässliche
politik ausgegeben hat leider hat sich
dies auch bei den beratungen des
verteidigungshaushaltes gezeigt hinter
den vielen netten worten der ampel
koalitionäre verbiegen sich leider im
kern etat nur wenig gute taten weil das
so ist benötigen wir dringend das
angekündigte 100 milliarden
sondervermögen und weil meine fraktion
die notwendigkeit sieht hat sie sich
proaktiv in die verhandlungen
eingebracht und trägt neben einen
anderen notwendigkeiten auch die
änderung des grundgesetzes mit ohne
diese zusätzliche mittel sie ist nämlich
ziemlich düster im einzelplan 14 aus ein
beispiel dazu es war gut dass
kurzfristig und unbürokratisch die
beschaffung der persönlichen ausrüstung
für alle soldatinnen und soldaten
beschleunigt vorgezogen wurde für mich
wäre es allerdings an dieser stelle
logisch gewesen wenn die zusätzlich
benötigten 2,3 milliarden euro die im
verteidigungshaushalt und ob zur
verfügung gestellt worden wären weit
gefehlt leider hatten ampel im
haushaltsausschuss genau das gegenteil
beschlossen jeder einzelne euro der für
besucher der für persönliche ausrüstung
und bekleidung und diesem jahr
ausgegeben wird muss an anderer stelle
von der bundeswert eingespart werden
ähnlich verhält es sich bei der dringend
notwendigen erhöhung der ausgaben für
betriebsstoffe fast die hälfte des
aufwuchses muss die bundeswehr im
gegenzug bei der beschaffung von
flugzeugen einsparen als ob die
bundeswehr etwas für gestiegene die soll
und benzinpreise könnte
fast schon konsequent dass die ampel
dann einfach weniger flugzeuge
beschaffen will dann meine damen und
herren braucht man logischerweise auch
weniger sprit meine sehr verehrten damen
und herren keine frage mit dem
sondervermögen bekommt die bundeswehr
endlich dringend notwendiges geld
darüber hinaus geht es hier aber um eine
ganz grundsätzliche frage nämlich wie
die politik zur bundeswehr steht auch
wenn die ampel koalitionäre
gebetsmühlenartig von wertschätzung und
respekt gegenüber der bundeswehr reden
schweden selbst bei vielen soldatinnen
und soldaten so einige fragezeichen über
deren köpfe meine damen und herren in
vorbereitung meiner rede habe ich mir
deshalb noch mal die alten anträge
angeschaut die insbesondere die grünen
und die fdp noch zu oppositionszeiten in
der vergangenen wahlperiode zum
verteidigungsetat gestellt haben ja otto
ich habe von dir gelernt das hast du in
den vergangenen jahren auch immer
gemacht ich habe ja da ein sammelsurium
gesehen an anträgen gerade bei den
grünen sie wollten will durch alle
themenfelder massiv einsparen okay gut
dass nun auch die grünen in der realen
welt einer wehrhaften demokratie
angekommen sind und
von der fdp wenn auch etwas weniger
drastisch gab es ähnliche anträge der
selbsternannten damaligen service
opposition anträge die aber niemals
erkennen ließen dass man einen
wesentlich größeren aufwuchs des einzel
plans herbeiführen wollte meine darunter
die cdu csu als partei der bundeswehr
geht auch in der opposition ihren
pragmatischen und deshalb glaubwürdigen
weg weiter deshalb haben wir eine ganze
reihe von vorschlägen gemacht und auch
wenn die ampel unsere anträge allesamt
abgelehnt hat freue ich mich dass einige
anregung von uns doch aufgenommen worden
sind so haben wir zb beantragt das
unsinnige verbot einer bewaffnung der
zukünftigen euro drohne aufzuheben auch
wenn zunächst abgelehnt kam dann in der
zweiten ausschussberatung ein leicht
umgeschriebene ampel antrag und macht
nun den weg für eine bewaffnung frei
ein anderes beispielen war unsere idee
die riesigen flächen auf den
hallendächern und anderer gebäude der
bundeswehr für den ausbau von
solarenergie zu nutzen im ausschuss
wurde diese idee von spd grünen und fdp
abgelehnt um nur kurze zeit später als
vorschlag aus der ampelkoalition in den
medien aufzutauchen
meine lieben kolleginnen und kollegen
als einer der über drei jahrzehnte in
der bundeswehr gedient hat liegt mir die
truppe wirklich am herzen und dann freue
ich mich auch für unsere soldatinnen und
soldaten auch für unsere zivilen
angestellten über jeden einzelnen
vorschlag den sie von uns zwar zunächst
ablehnen aber dann in die bei nächster
gelegenheit doch als eigene idee
verkaufen und umsetzt meine sehr
verehrten damen und herren wir
beschließen einen gesamthaushalt bei dem
aus meiner sicht noch viele fragen offen
sind gerade auch mit blick auf eine
rekordneuverschuldung und den vielen
ausgabe steigerungen da hätte ich mir
eine bessere priorisierung gewünscht
zugleich ist es mir aber enorm wichtig
in der aktuellen situation die chancen
für unsere bundeswehr zu nutzen endlich
ist es nicht nur die union die von einer
chronischen unterfinanzierung der
bundeswehr spricht und dies ändern will
endlich sind es sind sie scheinbar die
meisten hier im hause einig und wir
wissen dass ein beschaffungsprozess dass
da nicht nur ein reförmchen notwendig
ist sondern eine reform um diese
prozesse zu beschleunigen endlich
erhalten die soldatinnen und soldaten
für ihren dienst aus den meisten
fraktionen dieses hauses den
angemessenen respekt lassen sie uns in
diesem sinne weiter arbeiten für die
sicherheit unseres landes und für unsere
bundeswehr herzlichen dank für ihre
aufmerksamkeit
soweit ingo gädechens ja die erste der
erste redebeitrag zum
verteidigungsetat und auf ihn antworten
wird nun direkt die
bundesverteidigungsministerium christine
lambrecht
auch präsidentin meine sehr geehrten
damen und herren der aufbau der
bundeswehr ab 1955 gründete auf einer
großen parteiübergreifenden verfassungs
koalition richard jäger von der union
erich mende aus der fdp und natürlich
der große helmut schmidt und viele mehr
sie haben geschichte geschrieben durch
die gründung der bundeswehr als
parlamentsarmee und heute stehen wir
erneut vor einer grundlegenden zäsur der
brutale russische angriffskrieg wird uns
schmerzhaft eine lang verdrängte
tatsache vor augen wer in freiheit leben
will braucht militärische stärke um
diese freiheit zu verteidigen
uns in diesem entscheidenden moment
steht unser parlament erneut in großer
geschlossenheit hinter seiner armee eine
verfassungs koalition aus ampel und
union und gemeinsam werden wir das
größte ertüchtigung paket in der
geschichte der bundeswehr im grundgesetz
verankern ein sondervermögen von 100
milliarden euro mit einem großen ziel
wir wollen die bundeswehr wieder zu dem
machen was sie sein muss eine
leistungsfähige am medien kernauftrag
voll erfüllen kann unser land und unser
bündnis zu verteidigen man sammle über
jahrzehnte wurde unsere truppe strebt
nicht verträglich vernachlässigt und
heruntergewirtschaftet und das hat
spuren hinterlassen
die ausrüstung ist auf kante genäht und
vielfach nicht einmal das und das sehen
wir gerade jetzt wo mitten in europa ein
brutaler krieg tod bestehen in diesem
krieg fest an der seite der ukraine und
diese bundesregierung hat eine für unser
land historische entscheidung getroffen
wir liefern waffen in ein kriegsgebiet
wir liefern waffen in die ukraine
millionen schuss munition
tausende panzer abwehr minen
panzerfäuste und flugabwehrraketen 7
hochmoderne panzerhaubitzen 2000 schwere
artillerie an der wir die ukrainische
armee auch ausbilden und der balkon sie
haben es völlig richtig gesagt 21 tage
wären zu kurz für diese ausbildung und
deswegen sind auch 42 tage das ist ganz
wichtig damit die soldaten die dann mit
diesem hochmodernen gerät kämpfen auch
entsprechend ausgebildet sind und
dafür dafür für das was ich eben auch
gezählt habe dafür sind wir an die
bestände der bundeswehr gegangen und
bewerten dass wo immer möglich auch
weiter in enger abstimmung mit unseren
verbündeten machen wie zum beispiel bei
den mehrfach raketenwerfern in
abstimmung mit den usa meine damen und
herren zur wahrheit gehört aber auch
gestoßen hier an unsere grenzen und als
deutsche verteidigungsministerin muss
und werde ich sicher stellen dass wir
selbst verteidigungsfähigkeiten und dass
wir unsere bündnis pflichten auch
wahrnehmen können und deshalb nutzen wir
zur unterstützung der ukraine viele wege
direkt von der industrie flugabwehr
panzer geb haben einschließlich
ausbildung und munition und damit kann
man dann kritische infrastruktur
schützen ausdrücklich auf wunsch der
ukraine und ich muss ehrlich zugeben ich
schreib mir manchmal die augen wenn ich
selbst ernannte experten in talkshows
höre die dann sich darüber lächerlich
und lustig machen dass diese munition
die damit geliefert würde nur für
soundsoviel minuten ausreichen würde ja
wenn man auf dauerfeuer stellen würde
aber niemand der auch nur einigermaßen
eine ahnung davon hat niemand diesen
getragen nutzt creme auf diese idee denn
dann wäre nicht nur die munition
verbraucht auch das feuerwerk ab und wer
kommt auch so eine alberne idee und das
muss ich sagen weil solch ernsthaften
entscheidungen bei solch ernsthaft
ernsthaften thema da würde ich mir
manchmal da würde ich mir manchmal ein
bisschen mehr ernsthaftigkeit wünschen
und nicht nur die gier nach der flotten
überschrift meine damen und herren
ein weiterer weg über den wir die oper
in unterstützen ist der ringtausch
zuletzt mit tschechien die schwere
waffen die schwere waffen sowjetischer
bauart liefern und für die ukraine eben
ohne ausbildung sofort einsetzbar und
wir helfen dabei die tschechischen
lücken zu schließen aus industrie
beständen und auch mit griechenland
organisieren wir einen solchen
ringtausch und nicht zuletzt
unterstützen wir die ukraine mit sehr
viel geld geld für waffen und munition
und auf diesen beschriebenen wegen auf
diesen vielfältigen wegen helfen wir
wirksam ohne dass wir die bestände der
bundeswehr unverantwortlich sprechen und
das ist auch immens wichtig denn gerade
jetzt haben wir große aufgabe und es
geht doch darum auch ein verlässlicher
partner im bündnis zu sein und deswegen
geht es darum auch die ostflanke die
nato ostflanke zu stärken denn auch da
schauen unsere osteuropäischen
alliierten sehr genau hin was wir tun
deswegen was mir am mars mir wichtig
gleich zu beginn meiner amtszeit die
präsenz zu verstärken in litauen in der
slowakei dafür zu sorgen dass er politik
in rumänien möglich war und auch unsere
unsere präsenz in der ostsee und auch
als logistische drehscheibe der nato
sind wir besonders gefordert diese
aufgaben können wir erfüllen aber ich
muss ihnen auch sagen es sind mammut
aufgaben und die aufgaben der bundeswehr
werden noch weiter wachsen was das
bedeutet ist klar es muss schluss sein
mit der vernachlässigung der bundeswehr
und es muss schluss sein bezögen und
zaudern und daher ist es richtig
sie werden sich gleich noch freuen meine
damen und herren da ist es wichtig dass
der diesjährige
verteidigungshaushalt deutlich steigen
wird um rund 3,5 milliarden gegenüber
dem plan gegenüber dem ursprünglichen
entwurf und das ist ein wichtiges
zeichen mit diesen jetzt rund 50 4
milliarden haben wir eine solide
grundlage für den betrieb unserer
bundeswehr und gerade auch dafür
wichtige rüstungsgüter an zu schaffen
und dafür bin ich dankbar aber es sieht
sage ihnen auch es ist viel zu wenig
geld um die versäumnisse der
vergangenheit nachhaltig auszubügeln und
das wird schon an einem einzigen
beispiel wir brauchen alleine 20
milliarden euro um unsere ausgehöhlten
munitionsvorräte aufzufüllen auf nato
niveau und deshalb ist es so wichtig
dass jetzt neben dem
verteidigungshaushalt auch das
sondervermögen kommt 100 milliarden
zusätzlich und damit können wir die
dringendsten fähigkeitslücken nicht nur
identifizieren sowie das lange geschehen
ist lange lamentiert wurde aber jetzt
können diese lücken auch geschlossen
werden meine damen und herren und dieses
geld ist gut investiert
es geht um unsere fähigkeiten zur
landes- und bündnisverteidigung und
deswegen ist es gut dass schluss ist mit
kaputt sparen beziffern und zaudern vor
allen dingen auch schluss damit dass
wichtige entscheidungen viel zu lange
verschleppt wurden die tornado nachfolge
jahre lang ging es nicht voran jahrelang
wurde diese entscheidung verschleppt und
jetzt sie in chats ist sie entschieden
es soll die f35 werden die bewaffnung
der drohnen zum schutz unserer
soldatinnen und soldaten
wer hat es denn durchgesetzt haben sonst
wir setzen uns jetzt durch lassen
entscheidungen oder eine ganz wichtige
entscheidung eine ganz wichtige
entscheidung wer wollte denn die
soldatinnen und soldaten mit
persönlicher ausrüstung 20
31 man muss sich auf der zunge zergehen
lassen 20
31 erst ausstatten das ist vorgezogen
worden das geht deutlich schneller jetzt
sechs jahre früher das nenne ich mal
konsequentes handeln und eben nicht
zögern und zaudern und
jetzt lassen sie mich noch eine
entscheidung verkünden die ebenfalls
viel so lange verschleppt wurde ich habe
die frage ganz oft gehört glaubt seit
dem ersten tag meiner amtszeit was
machen sie mit den schweren
transporthubschrauber
warum wurde diese entscheidung denn
nicht früher getroffen weil man
bezaubert und gezaudert hat und jetzt
ist schluss damit die entscheidung ist
gefallen wir wollen das ist der job ist
und dass das geht uns das habe ich sehr
wohl mit all denjenigen die bei mir im
hause gute ratschläge geben können
beraten bei mir im hause mit denen habe
ich das beraten nämlich zum beispiel den
generalinspekteur der bundeswehr mit den
inspekteuren der luftwaffe und des
heeres und wir haben sehr wohl gründlich
die fork nachteile abgewogen und
deswegen haben wir uns genau für dieses
modell entschieden es ist erprobt es ist
das rückgrat des europäischen luft-
transports und mit diesem modell stärken
wir unsere kooperationsfähigkeit in
europa und natürlich für all diejenigen
die fragen gestellt haben ob es
vergleichsangebote gab natürlich haben
wir wie und deswegen kann ich ihnen auch
sagen wir bekommen eine größere flotte
durch diese entscheidung und damit auch
mehr flexibilität und deswegen ist es
die richtige entscheidung für unser und
so muss erklärt werden und so muss auch
übrigens agiert werden beim
beschaffungswesen und jetzt schaue ich
noch mal genau was ist denn da in der
letzten amtszeit zu geschehen das gilt
dann recht schnell so gut wie nichts es
gab zwar teure berater es gab zwar große
pläne aber es ist nicht umgesetzt worden
soviel zum zögern und zaudern in den
ersten wochen habe ich entschieden dass
gezogen und 20 prozent aller aufträge
aus der bundeswehr freihändig vergeben
werden können und damit deutlich weniger
bürokratie deutlich weniger bürokratie
ansetzt und die entsprechenden
ressourcen freigesetzt werden große
projekte es ist endlich entschieden dass
wir die möglichkeit nutzen vom
europäischen vergaberecht abzuweichen
nämlich immer dann wenn es die nationale
sicherheit betrifft und dringlich ist wo
waren denn da die entscheidungen aus dem
vergangen aus der vergangenheit jetzt
wird es angewandt und es wird noch viel
viel mehr kommen die eckpunkte paket
liegt auf dem tisch meine damen und
herren ich bin zur beschleunigung bereit
ich bin dazu bereit zu handeln schluss
mit zögern und zaudern
meine damen und herren wir haben jetzt
eine historische chance wir können die
versäumnisse der vergangenheit ausbügeln
und die bundeswehr wieder voll auf die
beine stellen und lassen sie uns diese
chance gemeinsam nutzen so wie damals in
den gründungsjahren
1955 in einer großen partei übergreifend
der koalition für unsere parlamentsarmee
es sind unsere soldatinnen und soldaten
die unsere freiheit verteidigen unsere
freiheit unsere demokratie stehen wir
geschlossen hinter hin vielen dank
die bundesverteidigungsministerium
hierzu ihre mehta und im hintergrund der
laufen sozusagen noch die verhandlungen
bzw
die absprachen vor allem in der union zu
den 100 milliarden
sondervermögen denn heute morgen war ja
anders als geplant im verteidigungs und
haushaltsausschuss
keine abstimmung zu dem sondervermögen
weil die union
auch vorbehalte hat gegen den
wirtschaftsplan beziehungsweise die
aufteilung welche waffengattung wie viel
geld bekommen soll heute abend gibt es
eine sondersitzung des haushalts- und
finden
verteidigungsausschusses zu diesem thema
damit das sondervermögen am freitag mit
dem haushaltsplan abgestimmt werden
könnte verkaufen und auch für dumm
halten würden und er hat auch gesagt
dass die bürger eben genau das nicht
sind und als ich das so hörte musste ich
unweigerlich an den beratungs verlauf in
diesem verteidigungsetat und an die
debatte zum sondervermögen denken denn
alle anderen parteien die hier im hause
sitzen schon auf die eine oder andere
weise genau das sie verkaufen die
menschen für dumm da haben wir zum einen
eine regierung aus spd grünen fdp eine
linke regierung die selbst kräftig dabei
mitgeholfen hat die bundeswehr so
rettungslos kaputt zu sparen das sie
jetzt in einem so schlechten zustand ist
dass man um die verteidigungsfähigkeit
in diesem land ernsthaft besorgt sein
muss
genau diese linke regierung mischt jetzt
ihre hände in unschuld und schwingt sich
nun zum retter der bundeswehr auch wir
haben es gerade von der
verteidigungsministerin gehört aber
eigentlich hat sie immer hat sie noch
nicht bei den blassesten schimmer wie
sie mit diesen scherbenhaufen umgehen
soll der fdp müsste eigentlich aus
haushalterischen gründen hier schon im
dreieck springen aber was interessiert
die minister das liberale geschwätz von
gestern die union wird nicht müde zu
betonen dass sie ja schon immer für die
bundeswehr war und dass nur die spd
schuld daran ist dass unsere truppen
nicht besser ausgestattet wurde dazu
muss man aber einfach mal festhalten
dass die deutsche regierungschefin 16
jahre lang angela merkel hieß und das
auch das verteidigungsministerium 16
jahre lang in den händen der union war
16 jahre indem sie die missstände in der
bundeswehr bestenfalls verwaltet und
nichts gegen den fortschreitenden
verwaltung streitkräfte unternommen
haben
ja es gab seit 2014 etat erhöhung aber
was ist eigentlich mit diesem geld
passiert da fallen einem dann leider nur
diverse beschaffungsskandale und berater
affären ein und für diesen mist haben
sie frau von der leyen dann auch noch
zur präsidentin der europäischen
kommission gefördert dann haben wir auch
natürlich die alles entscheidende
ausrede für alles und jeden der russe
ist schuld früher war alles friede
freude eierkuchen und das brauchte doch
gar keine armee mehr und überhaupt
konnte man durch die wahrnehmung der
eigenen sicherheitsinteressen gepflegt
den amerikanern aufbürden dass zwei
prozent ziel hat hier niemanden
interessiert im gegenteil man war noch
empört als ex-präsident trump forderte
deutschland möge doch endlich mal seine
bündnisverpflichtungen erfüllen und das
führt uns jetzt direkt zu dem elefanten
im raum den keiner hier benennen will
sie alle haben dir dabei mitgemacht dass
die bundeswehr so heruntergewirtschaftet
wurde dass man den entstandenen schaden
nur noch mit der aufnahme massive
schulden oder durch harte einschnitte im
gesamthaushalt beheben kann wenn man das
prinzip eines ausgeglichenen haushalts
nicht aufgeben und dabei die
sicherheitsinteressen deutschlands nicht
preisgeben will dann geht das nur über
radikale kürzungen in sämtlichen anderen
etats
und das ist die fürchterliche wahrheit
vor der wir hier alle stehen das ist die
riesige hypothek die sie allen bürgern
dieses landes durch ihre
verantwortungslosigkeit und ihre laxe
haushaltspolitik in der vergangenheit
aufgebürdet haben ich habe frau
ministerin lambrecht in den beratungen
gefragt was wir denn machen wenn das 100
milliarden euro sondervermögen
aufgebraucht ist sie hat geantwortet das
ist natürlich eine möglichkeit wäre ein
neues sondervermögen aufzulegen aber
dass sie selbstverständlich das nicht
möchte schon klar ich glaube ihnen kein
wort ein souveränes land muss sich
verteidigen können daran führt kein weg
vorbei
das haben wir hier auch immer wieder
gesagt aber mit ihrer haushaltspolitik
laufen wir auf eine dauerhafte
finanzierung unserer parlamentsarmee aus
schulden zu allen gegenteiligen
bekundungen zum trotz natürlich könnte
man das noch verhindern aber alle
anderen fraktionen haben in den
haushaltsberatungen deutlich gemacht
dass sie zu dem dafür erforderlichen
sparkurs nicht bereit sind wenn sie
diesen weg also gehen dann sollten sie
wenigstens so ehrlich sein und den
bürgern darüber die wahrheit sagen denn
das haben die bürger nicht nur verdient
darauf haben sie auch ein recht vielen
dank für ihre
wenn die einzelpläne des
bundeshaushaltes hier zum zweiten mal
das parlament beschäftigen also wie in
dieser woche zweite beratung dann ist es
üblich dass aus dem haushalts die
jeweiligen berichterstatter aus dem
haushaltsausschuss hier zu beginn von
den verschiedenen fraktionen noch einmal
den blick auf die kosten werfen und
berichterstatter für die grünen für den
einzelplan ist sebastian schäfer
kolleginnen und kollegen die zeitenwende
in der verteidigungspolitik ist
angekommen wir beschließen heute den
gemessen an bit und am haushalt grössten
verteidigungshaushalt seit 1992 die
friedensdividende man leider nicht mehr
fließen der brutale russische
großangriff auf die ukraine vom 24
februar stellt eine neue
eskalationsstufe da dieser krieg läuft
in unterschiedlicher intensität seit
2014 wir wussten seit dem dass wir in
sachen landes und bündnisverteidigung
mehr tun müssen der einzelplan 14 ist
auch sehr deutlich angewachsen es ist
dabei den trotz mehr als 50 milliarden
euro die zusätzlich ausgegeben wurden
also einem halben sondervermögen nicht
gelungen investitionsstau aufzulösen und
eine angemessene ausrüstung unserer
bundeswehr sicherzustellen
das liegt vor allem an den problemen bei
der beschaffung
aber leider auch an wahlkreis interessen
die eben nicht immer deckungsgleich sind
mit den interessen der bundeswehr
ein besonderes negativbeispiel
stellen die beiden marine die schiffe da
da scheint es ja eine ganze reihe von
fehlern gegeben zu haben die wir jetzt
teuer bezahlen klar ist wir müssen diese
militärischen tanker schnellstmöglich
erneuern damit wir die umweltschutz
vorgaben einhalten und die modelle aus
den 70er jahren endlich abraten können
erhalt industrieller kern fähigkeit darf
nicht bedeuten dass die kosten nicht zu
beachten sind wir gehen hier ja
bekanntlich mit steuergeld um das uns
die bürgerinnen und bürger an vertrauen
entsprechend groß ist unsere
verantwortung gerade bei den summen um
die es in diesem einzelplan geht
wenigen mittel sind also nur eine seite
der medaille
es sind auch zeitgemäße strukturen um
dieses jetzt gehen muss in der
beschaffung aber auch in der bundeswehr
selbst verantwortlichkeiten müssen klar
sein entscheidungen dürfen nicht
permanent zentralisiert werden sondern
müssen wieder viel stärker auch
dezentral getroffen werden können der
russische angriffskrieg zeigt wie
zentral heute auch die cyber abwehr für
eine armee und die landesverteidigung
sein kann es ist bedauerlich dass das
sondervermögen nicht genutzt werden kann
und damit auch die dringend notwendigen
investitionen im bereich der cyber
sicherheit und beim zivilschutz
abzusichern diese investitionen müssen
jetzt an anderer stelle im
bundeshaushalt finanziert werden
im haushaltsverfahren haben wir
beschlossen dass die reform des
beschaffungswesens jetzt zügig
angegangen werden muss über die
beschleunigung der vergabeverfahren
hinaus geht es zur schnellen stärkung
unserer bündnis und
verteidigungsfähigkeit darum markt
verfügbare systeme bei der beschaffung
zu priorisieren es geht darum die
gemeinsame europäische zusammenarbeit zu
suchen und möglichst gemeinsam zu
bestellen um nicht zuletzt geht es darum
den mut zu haben die strukturen und
prozesse in der beschaffung zu
vereinfachen insbesondere dafür muss
auch das beschaffungsamt endlich
ausreichend personal und expertise
erhalten der haushaltsausschuss erwartet
quartalsberichte zu den fortschritten
bei den reformen der rechnungshof wird
das eng begleiten wir setzen auch darauf
dass die bisherigen maßnahmen noch mal
genau beleuchtet werden die leichtere
auftragsvergabe die anhebung der vergabe
grenze von 1000 auf 5000 euro und auch
das handgeld die erhöhung des handgeld
für die kommandeure dass wir im
haushaltsausschuss beschlossen haben die
umsetzung effizienter beschaffungs
strukturen ist eine große aufgabe für
das verteidigungsministerium wir werden
am erfolg auch die arbeit von frau
ministerin messen eine reine
beschleunigung des vergabeverfahrens
reicht dafür nicht aus
ich will hier bewusst nicht mehr über
die vergangenheit sprechen das hilft uns
nicht weiter die alte bundesregierung
hat zumindest in den letzten beiden
jahren schon kleine korrekturen bei den
investitionen vorgenommen mit dem nun zu
beschließenden haushalt 20 22 und dem
sondervermögen werden wir die
fähigkeitslücken der bundeswehr im
rahmen der internationalen
bündnisfähigkeit jetzt zügig schließen
wir stellen die mittel zur verfügung für
eine zeitgemäße aufgabenorientierte
ausstattung für unsere soldatinnen und
soldaten und die bundeswehr die
bundeswehr wird jetzt anders als die
union im einundzwanzigsten jahrhundert
ankommen
wir haben in einem eilverfahren die
mittel zur verfügung gestellt um eine
persönliche vollausstattung aller
soldatinnen sicherzustellen
ihrem potenziell sehr gefährlichen
auftrag müssen unsere soldatinnen
bestmöglich geschützt nachkommen können
das sind wir unserer parlaments ami
schuldig herzlichen dank
was jan schäfer war es für die grünen
obmann im haushaltsausschuss aber vor
allem auch berichterstatter für diesen
einzelplan ebenso berichterstatterin für
die linke zu dem einzelplan gesine
lötzsch
damen und herren der krieg russlands
gegen die ukraine muss sofort beendet
werden die russische armee muss sich
zurückziehen und ich fordere die
bundesregierung auf alles zu tun damit
es zu einem sofortigen waffenstillstand
kommt
und
ich will auch mal in einer klarheit
sagen heute schon in der vergangenen
dekade so komische zwischenbemerkung
gehabt hätten wir als winkel irgendeinen
einfluss auf putin dann hätte es diesen
krieg nicht gegeben es gibt keine rechts
sitzen politiker aus meiner partei die
sich mit putin getroffen haben in den
anderen parteien sieht das anders aus
meine damen und herren wir mal es in
einer kleid zu sagen
haben und herren mit spd fdp grünen und
der union hat sich die größte koalition
aller zeiten zusammengefunden um ein
gigantisches konjunkturprogramm für die
rüstungsindustrie zu starten wir als
linke sagen ganz klar es darf kein neues
wettrüsten in dieser welt geben es darf
kein dritter weltkrieg riskiert werden
wir müssen alles tun um den frieden zu
bewahren erwärmt haben
und für die erstellung des 100
milliarden euro auf rüstungsprogramms
haben sie nur 100 tage gebraucht zum
vergleich die angekündigte
kindergrundsicherung wollen sie uns erst
zum ende der legislaturperiode vorlegen
was wären also 1000 trage ich finde es
kann doch nicht sein dass ein ganz
langsam sind wenn es im kampf gegen
kinderarmut geht und ganz schnell wenn
es um die interessen der
rüstungsindustrie giert das ist ein
missverhältnis ein trauerspiel das darf
so nicht weitergehen
es ist der koalitionsvertrag
unterschrieben wurde stand der
aktienkurs von rheinmetall bei knapp 83
euro am dritten mai stand die aktie
schon bei
222 euro und 40 cent das ist fast eine
verdreifachung des kurses da knallen die
korken bei den besitzern dieser aktien
und ich denke die dürfen wir nicht
finanzieren das ist der falsche weg weil
damen und herren und ich will auch die
grünen daran erinnern dass wir mal dafür
gekämpft haben dass die
rüstungsindustrie von der eu als nicht
nachhaltig eingestuft wird warum haben
sie das vergessen liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen von den grünen kehren sie zu
dieser auffassung zurück
und der rüstungs genuss der
bundesregierung ist es auch zu verdanken
dass rheinmetall in den dax 40
aufsteigen wird wir lehnen solche
staatlichen investitionen in der arten
der todbringende aktien ab mein land
haben es darf nicht vergessen werden
dass ihr das hat ja der probleme vor mir
schon zugegeben dass die 100 milliarden
euro sondervermögen zusätzlich zum ganz
normalen
militärhaushalte zur verfügung stehen
und dafür sind allein in diesem jahr
50,4 milliarden vorgesehen und nach nato
kriterien berechnet sind es sogar 55,6
milliarden euro sie geben also damit
zusätzlich zu dem 100 milliarden
sondervermögen für das militär in diesem
jahr mehr geld aus als insgesamt für
bildung forschung familien senioren
frauen jugend wohnungsbau und
wirtschaftliche zusammenarbeit das geht
so nicht weiter wir müssen in frieden
investieren meine damen und herren
das ist auch ein ammenmärchen dass die
bundeswehr kaputtgespart worden wäre
olaf scholz der bundeskanzler damals
finanzminister hat in seiner amtszeit
als finanzminister für einen aufwuchs
bei der bundeswehr gesorgt und zwar
addiert um
38,5 milliarden euro und das ist ja
wirklich nichts meine damen und herren
und nicht nur wir auch der
bundesrechnungshof aber auch sicher
viele soldatinnen und soldaten stellen
sich zu recht die frage wo ist denn das
viele geld für die bundeswehr geblieben
wo ist es geblieben und wir hören katri
probleme beschaffungs probleme und nun
soll es ein bundeswehr beschaffungs
beschleunigungsgesetz geben dass solche
probleme lösen aber ich glaube es um
probleme liegen ganz woanders die liegen
nämlich in knallharten wirtschaftlichen
interessen herr kollege vor mir hat das
beispiel dazu recht sagt die bremer
lürssen werft wird für die bundeswehr
zwei tankschiffe für 870 millionen euro
bauen bundeswehr intern wurde dieser
preis als exorbitant hoch bezeichnet und
das beschaffungsamt wurde beauftragt den
preis zu überprüfen das amt stellte fest
dass der preis um
250 millionen euro zu hoch ist und
trotzdem oder dieser überteuerte vertrag
geschlossen meine damen und herren geht
es den wirklich um eine bessere
ausrüstung der bundeswehr
oder geht es um hohe gewinne für die
rüstungsindustrie da müssen sie sich
entscheiden wir als linke sagen wir
brauchen abrüstung wir brauchen eine
friedliche weltordnung und ich erwarte
dass die bundesregierung dafür kämpft
vielen dank
und für die fdp erteile ich das wort
carsten kleiner und er komplettiert
sozusagen die riege der berichterstatter
für diesen einzelplan für die fdp in dem
fall
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen natürlich hat
der verbrecherische und
völkerrechtswidrige angriffskrieg den
wladimir putin über die ukraine gebracht
hat war das bestimmende moment der
verhandlungen zum einzuplanen des
verteidigungsministeriums und wir sind
uns denke ich alle klar dass wladimir
putin diesen krieg nicht gewinnen darf
dass die nato und deutschland kein
aktiver teilnehmer an diesem
kriegsgeschehen werden darf und dass wir
alles tun müssen um unsere freundinnen
und freunde in der ukraine zu
unterstützen ohne dabei unsere bündnis
und verteidigungsfähigkeit entscheidend
zu gefährden und genau für diese
verteidigungsfähigkeit haben wir
gemeinsam die koalition aus spd grünen
und fdp in diesen haushaltsberatungen
die entscheidenden weichenstellungen
vorgenommen wir haben dem haushalt den
kernhaushalt raum ministerin in der
planung für diese legislaturperiode
schon über neun milliarden euro
zusätzlich an mittel zur verfügung
gestellt für investitionen in ausrüstung
material und ausstattung 9 milliarden
euro mehr als die große koalition
und herr kollege geht ich haben sich
wird es schon kurz erwähnen nicht glaube
es geht außerhalb des raumes oder hier
sitzt dennoch wir können uns zumindest
nicht an einen einzigen aufwuchs antrag
der union erinnern den wie abgelehnt
hätten und deshalb kann ich vielleicht
nur zurückgeben vielleicht arbeiten sie
noch mal ein bisschen oppositions
verhalten bevor sie das anderen leuten
vorwerfen aber
frau ministerin ich fand es auch ein
sehr schönes dass wir gemeinsam vor die
planer gezogen die vollausstattung für
die soldatinnen und soldaten mit 2,4
milliarden euro auf den weg gebracht
haben die vollausstattung die anstatt
2031 von 2024 25 den soldatinnen und
soldaten zu läuft und ich glaube das ist
auch und ein gutes zeichen unterstreicht
noch einmal die wertschätzung dieses
hauses ihnen gegenüber den menschen die
unseren frieden unsere freiheit und
unsere sicherheit jeden tag verteidigen
sie haben es angesprochen wir haben
die nachfolge des tornados die nukleare
teilhabe entschieden wir haben zuerst
einmal eine geschichte der
bundesrepublik deutschland die
bewaffnung von drohnen beschlossen wir
werden jetzt in kürze hier im parlament
ihre ihren vorschlag für die beschaffung
des schweren transporthubschraubers
bewerten und dann hier auch entscheiden
aber die wichtigste weichenstellung
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen die wir
ergriffen haben die werden wir am
freitag hoffentlich beschließen das ist
das sondervermögen für die bundeswehr
dieses sondervermögen bietet die chance
die verteidigungsfähigkeit
wiederherzustellen und dieses
verhandlungsergebnis zeigt deshalb in
dieser besonderen krisenreaktion auch
die handlungsfähigkeit dieser
ampelkoalition aus spd grünen und fdp so
einen großen kraftakt auf den weg zu
bringen
aber liebe kollegen kollegen ich möchte
sie von der in jona ausschließlich mit
einbeziehen denn es ist auch ein gutes
zeichen dass diese parlamentarische
demokratie dass die demokratischen
kräfte in diesem haus in dieser
krisenlage zusammenarbeiten dieses
vermögen auf den weg gebracht haben oder
auf den weg bringen werden wer sich
jetzt die entscheidungsgrundlage
anschaut und sich die genese noch mal
vor augen führt 100 milliarden euro für
zusätzliche ausstattung der bundeswehr
im grundgesetz verankert mit tilgung
verbunden eine verwendung für die
bundeswehr den wird klar dass natürlich
den freien demokraten am freitag die
entscheidungen die zustimmung leicht
fallen wird ja wir nehmen dafür liebe
kolleginnen kollegen 100 milliarden euro
schulden auf aber das sind nicht die
schulden der ampelkoalition das sind
auch erst recht nicht die schulden vom
bundesfinanzminister christian lindner
nein diese schulden sind der preis dafür
dass wir alle gemeinsam einer eklatanten
fehleinschätzung in den letzten
jahrzehnten aufgesessen sind nämlich
dass dienste wie denn die
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen der union
ich hätte das an dieser stelle gar nicht
so betont aber nachdem diese einlassung
heute in der generaldebatte waren ich
finde es richtig dass sie verantwortung
übernehmen in dieser situation denn ein
großteil dieses themas dieses projekt
ist auch ihrer verantwortung oder ihrer
nicht wahrnehmung von verantwortung den
letzten jahren geschuldet liebe
kolleginnen der union
und deshalb ist es wichtig dass wir mit
einer grundgesetzänderung auch dieses
sondervermögen in einer besonderen weise
im grundgesetz platzieren und damit auch
diese besonderheit abbilden aus diesen
100 milliarden euro rx natürlich auch
eine besondere verantwortung für uns
alle die verantwortung dass die mittel
am ende effizient und effektiv
ausgegeben werden und dass die
ausrüstungsgüter und das material
zeitgerecht und qualitativ hochwertig
und vor allem funktionsfähig am ende bei
der truppe ankommen und dieser
verantwortung liebe kollegen und
kollegen werden wir gerecht über den
wirtschaftsplan wohnungen die maßnahmen
abbilden darüber dass wir die
entscheidungshoheit dieses parlaments
des haushaltsausschuss noch mal
unterstreichen was wir als
ampelkoalition mit der 25 mio vorlage
schon im haushaltsverfahren getan haben
und darüber werden wir dieser
verantwortung gerecht dass wir das
beschaffungswesen die änderungen die
sich schon vorgenommen haben frau
ministerin nicht nur begrüßen dass wir
nicht nur weitere schritte fordern
sondern dass wir diesen verändert haben
sie bei diesem schluss kamen begleiten
wollen und das haben wir als andere in
den verhandlungen schon beschlossen dass
werden am freitag noch einmal bestätigen
wenn am ende kommt es darauf an
vielen dank
wer den verteidigungsetat gehen kann die
ampel mit ihrer mehrheit beschließen bei
dem sondervermögen das funktioniert es
nicht das ist ja nicht teil des
haushaltes soll im grundgesetz wagen hat
werden wir zwei drittel mehr da braucht
man die union hören wir mal florian hahn
den verteidigungspolitischen sprecher
den kollegen und kollegen um es
vorwegzunehmen der einzelplan 14 den die
regierung vorgelegt hat ist aus unserer
sicht ungenügenden wir werden ihn
deshalb nicht zustimmen ist keine
überraschung aber frau ministerin ich
möchte schon feststellen dass ihren
öffentlichen versprechungen den
verteidigungshaushalt entsprechend der
verteidigungspolitischen bedrohungslage
anzupassen sind sie nicht ausreichend
nachgekommen und mit bleiben sie der
regierungslinie treu es gibt eine
erhebliche diskrepanz
zwischen den vollmundigen ankündigungen
und dem was tatsächlich umgesetzt wird
und ich sagte zur unterstützung hier als
beispiel die sage ich nur unterstützung
für die ukraine seit wochen gibt es mit
blick auf die entsprechenden listen in
der geheimschutzstelle keinen
substanziellen unterstützungs aufwuchs
für die ukraine die kämpfen gerade ums
überleben und was tun wir sie feiern
sich für vereinbarungen neue zum
sogenannten ringtausch hier werden
umständliche
zeitraubende und qualitativ schlechte
tausche vorgenommen stadt direkt
verfügbare waffensysteme wie den
schützenpanzer marder oder den
kampfpanzer leopard 1 auf den weg an den
bombast zu bringen so können wir doch
nicht weitermachen kolleginnen und
kollegen
zukommt hinzu kommt dass ihre
parlamentarische staatssekretärin müller
im fernsehen behauptet so viel zum thema
was öffentlich so gesagt wird frau
ministerin es gebe eine nato
vereinbarung nachdem der keine
schützenpanzer westlicher bauart in die
ukraine geliefert werden soll das ist
schon sehr verwunderlich und hier frau
ministerin genau hier würde ich mir mehr
ernsthaftigkeit wünschen von ihren
staatssekretären und von der
bundesregierung dar denn es gibt eine
solche es gibt eine solche vereinbarung
schließlich das bestätigt nicht nur die
nachwuchs sondern musste sogar ihre
spd-parteivorsitzende saskia esken
öffentlichen räume und liebe kollegen
der ampel regierung mit diesem
politischen handelns machen sie nicht
nur sich selbst lächerlich sondern
schaden unserem ansehen bei unseren
bündnispartnern erheblich machen
deutschen deutschland zunehmend zum
gestört es bedurfte leider erst des
weckrufs vom 24 februar mit dem
schrecklichen angriffskrieg russlands
gegen die ukraine das auch spd und grüne
vor allem erkannt haben dass
einsatzbereite streitkräfte auch für uns
existenziell sind und frau ministerin
sie haben vorher gesagt dass wurde in
den letzten jahren
sträflich vernachlässigt da kann ich nur
sagen da haben sie recht aber mit dieser
sträfliche vernachlässigung da waren sie
wieder war die spd ganz ganz weit vorne
das thema vögel zögern und zaudern
kolleginnen und kollegen wir waren
diejenigen die immer dass zwei prozent
ziel eingefordert haben dass sie
verweigert haben wir waren die die seit
jahren seit über 80 die bewaffnung der
ohne ball in sieben dass die das
verhindert haben und die kolleginnen und
kollegen ist war auch die spd und das
war der finanzminister scholz der im
letzten sommer mehrere 25 mio vorlagen
die fix und fertig im ministerium lagen
einfach nicht weiter geleitet hat und
abgearbeitet hat die beispielsweise das
zweite los korvette und hier könnte ich
weitermachen es war die spd die das
verhindert hat und sich so einen
schlanken fuß zu machen nachdem sie in
den letzten 25 jahren geschlagene 21
jahre in dieser regierung mit saßen zu
sagen damit haben wir nichts zu tun und
jetzt gehen wir mal richtig gas auf
kosten des steuerzahlers nämlich durch
100 milliarden schulden zu machen das
ist ein gewaltig schlanker fuß um das
ganze auch mal zu unterstreichen möchte
ich mal zeigen sie haben ja nicht nur so
gehandelt sie haben damit ja auch noch
wahlkampf gemacht ich bin immer hier
eine anzeige zeigen und daraus vorlesen
da steht drauf wahlkampf anzeige der spd
zeit für mehr gerechtigkeit das will die
cdu teure ausrüstung vom panzer bis zur
drohne das will die spd kostenfreie
bildung von der kita bis zur uni das war
genau ihre brot und der hat deutschland
dazu gebracht und die bundeswehr wo sie
heute ist es war die spd die waffen
strecken verändern
deswegen ist es aber umso wichtiger dass
wir jetzt gemeinsam erkennen dass hier
viel zu tun ist und deswegen
müssen wir uns auch ganz genau über das
sondervermögen und erhalten wir sind
hier sehr sehr weit aber 100 milliarden
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen sind kein
klacks jede milliarde muss gut
investiert seien im sinne der unserer
bundeswehr und deshalb wollen wir als
union genau wissen wofür die ampel das
geld ausgeben will so ein riesiger berg
schulden darf nicht mit heißer nadel
gestrickt werden und deswegen hoffe ich
hier sehr auf die gespräche die wir
heute noch führen und dass wir dann
tatsächlich zu einem entsprechenden
abschluss kommen ich sage auch ganz
deutlich frau ministerin es geht jetzt
dann auch wenn die wenn das
sondervermögen auf den weg gebracht
werden kann dann geht es darum dass sie
dann auch liefern und ich sage ganz
deutlich wir brauchen weniger staat wir
brauchen mehr truppen wir brauchen
höhere einsatzbereitschaft und weniger
technokratische detailverliebtheit und
die eckpunkte des generalinspekteurs und
die umfangreiche arbeit um vorarbeit die
die inspekteure unter truppe für dafür
geleistet haben sie liegen auf eis wie
haben sie frau ministerin auf eis gelegt
aber die soldatinnen soldaten fragen
sich was wollen sie denn stattdessen und
sie fragen sich für was gibt es
eigentlich immer mehr stellen in ihrem
eigenen stand so haben sie zum beispiel
gleich zwei kommunikationschefs
angesichts der gelungenen kommunikation
der letzten woche fragt man sich wofür
aber das ist ein anderes thema wofür
haben sie ein ganzes referat mit
persönlichen referenten das gab es
wirklich so noch nie das sind immer neue
stäbe und neue bürokratische strukturen
stärkt das wirklich unsere
verteidigungsbereitschaft diesem weg
sehr geehrte kolleginnen und kollegen
diesen weg geht die union nicht mit und
deswegen legen wir den haushalt ab was
es tatsächlich wenn es tatsächlich um
die unterstützung der bundeswehr geht
dann haben sie uns immer an ihrer seite
das kann ich ihnen zu sagen herzlichen
dank ja und ob am freitag aber über das
sondervermögen abgestimmt werden kann da
gibt es im moment scheinbar an der union
florian hahn zumindest er hat morgen bei
meinem kollegen im phoenix interview
gesagt was er jetzt noch mal wiederholt
hat da kam er gerade aus dem
verteidigungsausschuss dass die union
noch ein paar fragezeichen hat die
scheinen bisher immer noch nicht
aufgelöst zu sein heute abend gibt es
sondersitzungen von verteidigungs und
haushaltsausschuss
wir brauchen wir brauchen was heute
gefordert es ist haltung und vor allem
wir müssen gemeinsam viel verantwortung
für die soldatinnen und soldaten in
unserem land übernehmen und es gab
zeiten wenn man kurze blick zurück
werfen wollen da war die kanzlerin bei
der cdu der verteidigungsminister bei
der cdu csu und der finanzminister war
bei der cdu also alles aus einem guss
und wenn das alles so wichtig gewesen
wäre die kanzler auch die richtigen
kompetenzen hätte man manches anders
entscheiden können aber
das war der kurze blick zurück der gute
alte philosoph aristoteles sagte schon
wir können den wind nicht ändern aber
wir können die segel richtig setzen sehr
geehrte damen und herren und genau das
machen wir mit diesen
verteidigungshaushalt und das machen wir
auch mit dem sondervermögen segel
richtig setzen der wind der uns aus
russland entgegen weht der ist ganz
schön stürmisch ist es ein neuer kabel
wir wissen nicht wann er abebbt dieser
verteidigungshaushalt leitet eine
zeitenwende ein lag der etat im
haushalts- jahr 2021 noch bei
46,9 milliarden euro tendenz damals
stagnierend hat das sich nach der rede
von bundeskanzler olaf scholz vom 27
februar verändert wir reden heute von
einem verteidigungsetat der 50 3
milliarden euro beinhaltet immerhin ein
plus von 7,3 prozent und bis 2026 sind
die finanzplanung vor dass er
kontinuierlich bei 5,1 milliarden euro
bleibt immerhin drei milliarden als noch
in unserer kroko geplanten finanzplanung
leider betrifft es dieses brutalen
angriffskrieges um zu erkennen dass die
bundeswehr besser moderne ausgestattet
werden muss dem kommt diese fortschritts
koalition jetzt nach danke wir an dieser
stelle für die soldatinnen und soldaten
einige sitzen ja heute hier im plenum
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen zu
steigen die ausgaben für militärische
beschaffungen in dem haushalt 22 auf
über 10 milliarden
damit sind wichtige beschaffungen
möglich im lkw-bereich beschaffungen im
rat der netten aufklärungssystem bereich
flug technisches gerät etc ausdrücklich
darauf hinweisen möchte ich dass wir
auch erst kürzlich 2,1 milliarden euro
für schutz ausstattung der soldaten soll
daten beschafft haben liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen damit aber nicht genug
äußere sicherheit muss kam aufgabe des
staates sein dafür braucht man eine
weitergehende umfassende vernünftige
ausstattung der bundeswehr die sicher
viel geld kostet danke an die opposition
dass sie sich ihrer staatspolitischen
verantwortung stellen der
grundgesetzänderung zu stimmen damit
zeigt deutschland außen wir sind eine
starke demokratie bei allem was uns
trennt gibt es vieles was uns auch
verbindet das sondervermögen wird 100
milliarden zur verfügung stellen diese
kreditermächtigung wird dazu beitragen
die zusagen an nato etc zu erfüllen das
signal an die partner in europa und nato
ist klar deutschland ist ein
zuverlässiger partner und wir sind uns
auch unsere neuen verantwortung bewusst
aus diesem sondervermögen lassen sich
dann endlich wichtige und regent mit
benötigte fähigkeiten
realisieren es wurden ja schon einige
angedeutet vom schweren
transporthubschrauber über die f 35
damit werden wir die bundeswehr zu einer
leistungsfähigen armee ausbauen die ihre
verteidigungs und bündnisfähigkeit
festigt unsere freiheit in europa
schützt das sind wir den menschen im
land aber unseren soldatinnen und
soldaten schuldig apropos schuldig nicht
nur die ausstattung muss auf vordermann
gebracht werden auch bei den
unterkünften ist sicherlich noch einiges
im argen auch hier sollten wir zügig
aktiv werden die unterkünfte sind oft
nicht mehr zeitgemäß und es mangelt an
ausstattung aber auch die ökologische
situation ist oft nicht so toll die
bundeswehr ist einer der größten
energieverbraucher
deutschland dh wir könnten hier
spannende und zügig ein
sanierungsprogramm machen und das
beinhaltet neben photovoltaik natürlich
auch andere ökologische maßnahmen und
ich glaube der gesetzgeber ist gut
aufgefordert wenn wir freiwillig mit
guten beispiel voran gehen wir fordern
ja auch im zuge des klimawandels hier
einiges auch den hausbesitzern in diesem
land ab in dem zusammenhang können wir
auch gebäulichkeiten von thw und soll in
dieses programm mit einnehmen man merkt
das hilft nicht nur dem klima wir werden
am ende geld sparen und es direkt zur
eigentlich glaubwürdigkeit bei meine
damen und herren wie bringt man die ps
auf die straße
die ministerin hat schnell mutig
reagiert und vieles hier auf den weg
gebracht damit dass alles schneller geht
es wurde schon erwähnt uns ist gelungen
innerhalb der koalition noch mal die
kommandeurs pauschale zu verdoppeln
meine damen und herren liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen ein großer teil dieses
geldes ist gut für uns schwarz kam sie
zum schluss sollten dann sage ich nur
noch danke an meine berichterstatter und
freue mich schon auf die nächsten
haushaltsverhandlungen die an kürze an
spielt für den haushalt 23 dankeschön
das ist der haushalt tierisch betrachtet
ein besonderes jahr durch die
bundestagswahl befinden wir uns immer
noch in der vorläufigen haushaltsführung
das ist üblich deswegen diese woche der
haushalt 2022 und dann schon bald im
september der haushalt 2023 der dann
beraten wird
kollegen und kollegen am 24 februar
begann der russische angriff auf die
ukraine zur überraschung aller wurde
hier vom bundeskanzler drei tage später
in der sondersitzung des bundestags dann
die schaffung eines sondervermögen
angekündigt also die aufnahme neuer
schulden außerhalb des etats zur
umgebung der grund gesetzlich
vereinbarten schuldenbremse
die sollte seiner aussage nach dazu
dienen die notwendige beschaffungen für
die bundeswehr planungs sicher
finanzieren zu können
erklärte der kanzler dass künftig das
zwei prozent ziel der nato dauerhaft
erreicht werden soll beide
koalitionsfraktionen gab es für diese
ankündigung von stehenden applaus bis
hin zu demonstrativen sitzenbleiben mit
verkniffenem gesicht alle varianten der
kenntnisnahme
nun eine solide finanzierung der
bundeswehr sowie die erreichung des 2
prozent ziels waren von anfang an
zentrale forderungen der alternative für
deutschland
dafür haben sie uns aus militaristen und
aufrechter verunglimpft nun ist es
politische leitlinie
das ist erst eines alarmruf durch den
krieg russlands gegenüber keine bedurfte
beweist nur eins die unfähigkeit die
hier schon immer regierenden parteien
für die sicherheit und wir verteidigen
unsere heimat und des deutschen volkes
sorge zu tragen
er weiß doch die spd hatte schon immer
ein problem mit der finanzierung der
bundeswehr und von rüstungsprojekten
forderungen wie lieber 6 prozent mehr
für bildung als zwei prozent für rüstung
macht man sich dort doch schon lange zu
eigen ebenso die grünen dort denkt man
deutsche verantwortung global es geht um
humanität klimawandel frauenrechte
demokratie jetzt fort oder den viel
zitierten vernetzten ansatz man ist aber
auch zu naiv oder vielleicht auch zu
verschlagen um den wählern eines klar zu
machen ich verfolge an der globalen
agenda führt zwangsläufig zu einem
globalen interventionismus
ja bei der fdp von christian lindner nun
davon durch das sondervermögen die
bundeswehr zu einer der zitat
schlagkräftigsten armeen in europa
aufzubauen
gleichzeitig will seine parteikollegin
danke für den zwischenruf und
vorsitzende des verteidigungsausschusses
frau strack-zimmermann gerade schwere
waffen von der bundeswehr abziehen um
die sich um die kleine zu schicken ein
vorschlag übrigens von dem sogar der
stellvertretende inspekteur der
bundeswehr warnt weil damit die
einsatzfähigkeit der streitkräfte
gefährdet wird
durch putins angriff auf die ukraine
brauchen wir aber antworten wie nun die
streitkräfte vom kopf auf die füße
gestellt werden können und dazu braucht
jetzt die wie immer geld
wenn das nicht ausreicht wie so oft bei
dieser bundesregierung werde ihre
schulden gemacht das nennt man dann
euphemistisch sondervermögen und ich
frage mich immer welcher marketing
findet eigentlich solche rhetorischen
liebe kerzen
mehr geld für die bundeswehr dringend
nötig keine frage für alternativen
fordert seit jahren die erreichen des
zwei prozent ziels der nato dieser
richtwert es jedoch eher ein politisches
statement dahinter steht das wissen dass
unsere nation weder die militärische
schlagkraft noch den
selbstbehauptungswillen hat einen
angriff wie in die ukraine derzeit
erlebt auch nur ansatzweise aufhalten
das versagen aller bundesregierungen
seit 1990
die bundeswehr kann schon seit jahren
ihren verfassungsmäßigen auftrag nimmt
die landesverteidigung sicherstellen
nicht erfüllen und dafür tragen alle
ehemaligen regierungspartei von spd
cdu/csu fdp und grünen die verantwortung
ihr versagen ihr jahrzehntelanges
spanner verteidigungshaushalt ließ die
bundeswehr das wär materialverhalten die
aussetzung der wehrpflicht übrigens
unter einem csu-verteidigungsminister so
wie ich hängen es wolle
schwerpunktverlagerung auf das krisen
management in auslandseinsätzen damit
den rest denn alles musste sich dem
vorrang des krisenmanagements
unterwerfen auch material grundbetrieb
und ausbildung zu tun und fähigkeiten
wurden abgebaut und teuer wieder
aufgebaut werden müssen sie weiter dem
material ist wie die immer noch um
verschlüsselte kommunikation im gefecht
er eine gefahr als eine hilfe
auch die munition beschaffung wurde
sträflich vernachlässigt die bundeswehr
sich andere munition und mario
intensiven verteilungskampf auch nur für
wenige tage durchhalten zu können
warum wurde es ein verantwortungsträgern
bekannt war änderte sich nichts alle
bisherigen haushalte stellt immer
ungenügende finanzmittel zur verfügung
100 milliarden euro für die bundeswehr
sind also dringend notwendig wenn sie
übernimmt wieder auf unser streitkräfte
ernsthaft wollen auch die bundeswehr
deutlich mehr geld und das über einen
längeren zeitraum ist erfordert künftig
an stetigen und berechenbaren aufwuchs
des verteidigungsetats
denn was geschieht wenn das sogenannte
sondervermögen in fünf jahren
aufgebraucht ist da wir dann hoch
moderne waffensysteme die nicht
einsatzbereit sind weil es an
ersatzteilen ausgebildeten personal und
den mittel zum betrieb fehlt
aber geld allein ist auch nicht die
lösung es muss auch richtig eingesetzt
werden die truppe musste das von ihr
benötigte material möglichst schnell
erhalten kontrolle waren verantwortungs
die fusion überbordenden bürokratismus
müssen vereine geht es weitaus enger die
bedarfsdeckung eingebunden werden die
historisch über kommende trennung von
streitkräften und wehrverwaltung muss
beendet werden
wir brauchen aber auch eine patriotische
wende wenn nur noch circa 30 prozent der
jungen deutschen bereit sind ihre heimat
zu verteidigen wenn die politische
führung glaubt heimat sein
problembehafteter begriff der positiv
umgedeutet werden müsse wie
bundesinnenminister ein fehler meint und
ist eben kein wunder wenn der wille der
gesellschaft am boden liegen dann läuft
in dieser gesellschaft etwas völlig
falsch
für uns alternative dagegen gilt auch
heute noch heraklit antike leitspruch
kämpfen soll das volk für das gesetz und
seine mauer
streitkräfte waren und sind der zentrale
ausdruck nationaler souveränität und
außenpolitische handlungsfähigkeit
starke streitkräfte sind ausdruck des
selbstbehauptungswillen seiner nation
ohne kampfkräftige streitkräfte gibt es
keine glaubwürdigkeit als bündnispartner
wir legen daher den einzelplan 14 ab ich
danke ihnen für ihre aufmerksamkeit
er sagt gerhold otten für die afg
fraktion und der nächste hier in der
aussprache
zum einzelplan verteidigung von philipp
krämer für die fraktion bündnis 90 die
grünen erst mit sich im
verteidigungsausschuss
präsidentin sehr geehrte kolleginnen
kollegen mit der verabschiedung des
bundeshaushalts und des geplanten
sondervermögens werden wir die
angestrebte zeitenwende in der deutschen
außen- und sicherheitspolitik weiter
vorantreiben und die bundeswehr spürbar
stärken neben dem volumen des einzelplan
14 von 50 milliarden euro werden wir
einmalig weitere 100 milliarden euro
bereitstellen um unsere verpflichtungen
innerhalb der nato erfüllen zu können
und dringend notwendige verbesserung der
ausstattung zu finanzieren wir sind
dabei folgende vier punkte wichtig
erstens zentral muss die verbesserung
der persönlichen ausstattung von
soldatinnen und soldaten seien die durch
den bund finanzierte persönliche
ausstattung muss endlich ein niveau
erreichen das zusatz beschaffungen
tiefel schutzbekleidung oder
wintermäntel aus persönlichen mitteln
entbehrlich macht zweitens
zweitens braucht transparentere planungs
und entscheidungsprozesse bei der
beschaffung die bundeswehr verfügt über
die hilfe nur notwendigen strukturen
leider dominierten in der vergangenheit
oft regionale oder industrie politische
entscheidungen und bei der anstehenden
beschaffung eines schweren
transporthubschraubers bietet sich eine
erste gute gelegenheit für das
verteidigungsministerium die eigenen
prozesse zu verbessern und uns
parlamentarierinnen und parlamentariern
eine nachvollziehbare
entscheidungsgrundlage zu geben
in der vergangenheit kam es bei den
einzelnen beschaffungs projekten und das
führte zu drittens zu erheblichen
verzögerung dass der einsatzfähigkeit
der systeme sowie nachträglichen
kostensteigerungen das hat konkrete
auswirkungen wie wir am temporären abzug
des a400m aus dem anti nash einsatz zur
stärkung der aus danke sehen können
unser fokus muss daher auf solche
investitionen liegen die für die
erfüllung des verteidigungs oder bündnis
auftrags benötigt werden und zur
zeitnahen verbesserung der
einsatzfähigkeit der bundeswehr führen
viertens ich möchte den bestmöglichen
schutz unserer soldatinnen und soldaten
wenn wir starts bürgerinnen und bürger
in uniform in lebensgefährliche
situationen senden möchte ich mir
jedenfalls gewiss sein alles für ihren
west möglichen schutz getan zu haben
daher ist es beispielsweise wichtig dass
wir über das sondervermögen
schnellstmöglich auch die fähigkeit
lücke in der luftverteidigung im nahen
nix bereich schließen zeitenwende meine
damen und herren bedeutet eine neue
positivere haltung zur
verteidigungspolitik und unseren
internationalen bündnissen eine bessere
ausstattung der bundeswehr entsprechend
der beschlossenen fähigkeiten und ein
effizienteres beschaffungswesen die
grundlage hierfür schaffen wir in dieser
woche und ich lade sie alle ein uns
dabei zu unterstützen herzlichen dank
und für die fdp fraktion erteile ich das
wort alexander müller
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen wir beschließen heute einen
haushalt der für die bundeswehr
historisch ist die 50,3 milliarden für
den einzelplan 14 sind ein historischer
rekordwert und wir liegen damit etwa
zehn prozent höher als in der
mittelfristigen finanzplanung der
regierung merkel für dieses jahr das
ganze gejammer der union ist daher
ziemlich geschauspielert vor allem wenn
man sich den ziemlich beschränkten
stellenwert der bundeswehr unter der
regierung merkel noch in erinnerung ruft
den heutigen zustand der bundeswehr
betrachtet und sich die ursachen dafür
mal überlegt
2022 wächst der verteidigungshaushalt
von den 46,9 milliarden des merkel
haushalts 20 21 auf 50,3 milliarden der
ampel also hören sie auf zu heulen und
zu heucheln liebe unionskollegen die
ampel erhöht den verteidigungshaushalt
und gemeinsam mit der union werden wir
on top nochmal 100 milliarden
sondervermögen oben drauf packen
als fdp war es uns besonders wichtig
dass das fähigkeitsprofil der bundeswehr
wieder erfüllt werden kann mit modernen
hightech gerät welches dann durchgängig
einsatzbereit ist und dafür benötigen
wir die vollen 100 milliarden euro
herein für die bundeswehr und außerdem
bei uns wichtig dass wir endlich das
zwei prozent ziel erreichen und es
mehrjährig auch durchhalten es ist kein
geheimnis dass wir die von uns
geforderten zwei prozent des
bruttoinlandsprodukts in den
koalitionsverhandlungen 21 noch nicht
durchsetzen konnten aber umso wichtiger
ist es dass die fortschritts koalition
dieses ziel jetzt durchsetzt und was uns
als fdp noch ganz besonders wichtig war
ist das ab 20 23 die schuldenbremse
wieder eingehalten wird und zwar
dauerhaft ein gehalten wird und deswegen
kommt das sondervermögen als gesonderter
satz ins grundgesetz um auch gesetzlich
ganz eindeutig zu regeln das
sondervermögen und die schuldenbremse
beide sauber abgebildet und eingehalten
werden
wir machen uns noch diese woche an die
beschleunigung der beschaffungsprozesse
wir arbeiten schon jetzt an dem gesetz
zur beschleunigung der beschaffung indem
wir sie entbürokratisieren werden und
indem beispielsweise die zeitaufwändigen
gerichtlichen nachprüfungsverfahren
deutlich eingeschränkt werden dieses
gesetz wollen wir schnellstmöglich auf
den weg bringen und danach machen wir
weiter mit der digitalisierung der
beschaffungsprozesse und den test
innovative beschaffungsverfahren anstatt
dem klassischen cpm prozess es ist ein
historischer tag für die ausrüstung und
die einsatzfähigkeit der bundeswehr auf
die wir alle stolz sein können und frau
präsidentin mich brauchen sie nicht zu
vertreiben die letzte halbe minute würde
ich gerne den nachfolgenden rednerin
strack zimmermann als gleichzeit auf ihr
konto gehen vielen dank
alexander müller war das für die fdp
schon mal eine minute redezeit für seine
fraktionskolleginnen ja erst der
sprecher für wehrtechnik und
beschaffungswesen und das
beschaffungswesen ja tatsächlich ein
dauerbrenner im zusammenhang auch mit
der bundeswehr
das soll unbedingt reformiert werden da
sind sich eigentlich alle einig
kollegen lassen sie mich beginnen mit
einem dank seinen dank an all diejenigen
die in den letzten tagen und wochen
intensiv und sicherlich auch hart an
diesem sondervermögen gearbeitet haben
darüber beraten haben es ist gut und es
ist richtig dass dieses sondervermögen
jetzt kommen sollen und es ist ebenso
wichtig dass hier die demokratische
mitte dieses hauses einigkeit gezeigt
hat ein ganz besonderer dank gilt und
dass wir die sie jetzt liebe kollegen
aus der abstraktion
nicht wundern ein ganz besonderer dank
gilt den fan kann meiner fraktion die
maßgeblich dazu beigetragen haben dass
diese 100 milliarden euro auch jetzt
ausschließlich für die bundeswehr zur
verfügung stehen und ihnen zugute kommen
es freut mich sehr
das ganz im sinne auch unsere
streitkräfte
dieser schritt war wie jetzt auch schon
mehrmals deutlich geworden ist auch
bitter nötig denn die bundeswehr ist
nicht
und war es auch vor dem 24
februar nicht das notwendige übel wie es
die jusos vorsitzende dieser tage noch
sagte nein sondern eine einsatzbereite
schlagkräftige und durchhaltefähig
bundeswehr muss bestandteil der
sogenannten
seitenwände sein die leser der letzten
drei monate zeigt uns nämlich auch wer
keinen krieg will darf nicht
ausschließlich auf diplomatie setzen
denn doch das ist eine lehre an diesen
tagen muss auch auf abschreckung setzen
und diesem ziel sollen auch die gut 50
milliarden euro dienen die dieses jahr
im einzelplan 14 der bundeswehr zur
verfügung stehen ein bestandteil und die
durchhaltefähigkeit der bundeswehr zu
gewährleisten ist die unterstützung der
aktiven truppe durch die vielen
engagierten reservistinnen und
reservisten und umso mehr wundert es
mich an dieser stelle dass die ampel
fraktionen unseren antrag zur migration
der software des werks wesen
informationssystems das sogenannte
wegesin sas sas pf abgelehnt haben ich
glaube allein der begriff der satz wesen
zeigt aus welchem zeitalter dieses
system stammt wenn im kriegsfall mehrere
zehntausend personen zeitgleich
herangezogen werden müssen dann darf ein
zusammen aus zeiten des kalten krieges
hier nicht der flaschenhals sein der die
aufwuchs fähigkeit der streitkräfte
behindert hier hätten wir uns als
unionsfraktion gewünscht dass die ampel
diesen kleinen aber doch sehr wichtigen
und notwendigen schritt mit geht dass es
leider nicht erfolgt liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen wir dürfen wenn wir hier
bei den diesjährigen haushalt
debattieren auch nicht die zukunft
den augen verlieren die zukunft des
krieges ist digital und auch dafür muss
unsere bundeswehr gut ausgerüstet sein
wir begrüßen dass ein erheblicher teil
des sondervermögens auch hierfür bereit
gestellt werden soll scheitern dürfen
diese wichtigen vorhaben im sinne der
digitalisierung der bundeswehr
allerdings nicht an der beschaffung die
umsetzung der projekte zur strategischen
kommunikation und oft
führungsfähigkeiten müssten jetzt
schnell angegangen werden und dürfen
nicht erst in zehn jahren einsatzfähig
sein wie wir es in der vergangenheit oft
erlebt haben und an dieser stelle muss
ich sagen frau minister und wundert mich
schon ein wenig ihrer amme sie genauso
auch die amnesie der spd-fraktion ich
erinnere ich mich gerne an die
koalitionsverhandlungen 2017 als das ein
ganz großes thema war das
beschaffungswesen zu beschleunigen und
wer dagegen war 2 nahles und herr schulz
die damaligen parteivorsitzenden die
damaligen parteivorsitzenden der spd und
setzten damit heute nichts mehr zu tun
haben wollen und sich hier hinstellen
vom minister sondern so tun als hätten
sie die letzten vier jahre in diesem
land keinerlei regierungsverantwortung
gab das ist wirklich zum schaudern an
dieser stadt
wir erwarten hier nicht nur die
ankündigung die sie gerade gemacht haben
in sachen beschleunigung verfahren was
die beschaffungen betrifft sondern
weitere konkrete vorschläge damit eben
auch dinge die digitalisierung schneller
vorangehen wir dürfen hier nicht
nachlassen denn häufig sind die
beschaffungs projekt über die wir gerade
aktuell diskutieren und die schlagzeilen
machen vielleicht im fokus wie die
schweren transporter schweren
transporthubschrauber oder auch
kampfpanzer sowie fregatten aber mit
auch dass es eine lehre dieser tage die
fähigkeiten im cyber und
informationsraum sind genauso
kriegsentscheidend lassen sie uns
gemeinsam hier dran bleiben herzlichen
dank für ihre aufmerksamkeit
und für die spd-fraktion spricht jörg
nürnberger
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen wenn wir heute
den verteidigungshaushalt diskutieren
ist dieser haushalt angesichts der
grundlegenden veränderungen der
sicherheitspolitischen lage in europa
nicht isoliert zu betrachten
wir müssen den haushalt
2022 immer in verbindung mit dem
sondervermögen von 100 milliarden euro
sehen als verteidigungspolitiker freue
ich mich sehr über die einigung mit der
union über das sondervermögen ich
erkenne ausdrücklich an dass die union
wenigstens dieses mal nicht der
versuchung nachgegeben hat ihre
parteitaktischen interessen über die
sicherheitsinteressen des landes zu
stellen sie folgen dem vorbild der spd
unsere maxime lautet nämlich immer erst
das land und dann die partei
angesichts der riesigen unbestrittenen
aufgaben stellt sich die frage woher
kommen wir eigentlich ein blick in die
geschichte ist hilfreich am ersten zehn
1986 also vor mehr als 35 jahren wurde
er als wehrpflichtiger zur luftwaffe
eingezogen wir verfügten damals allein
in der alten bundesrepublik über drei
arme kurs mit zwölf divisionen und vier
luftwaffen divisionen und insgesamt
495.000 soldat jünger im personal soll
all das wurde nach der ersten
zeitenwende die ich miterleben wurde
ganz aus wichtigen gründen zurück
gefahren wir haben die truppenstärke
reduziert das war alles folgerichtig
aber wir haben in den vergangenen jahren
auch etwas den fokus auf die landes- und
bündnisverteidigung verloren
in den drei vergangenen jahrzehnten
verlagert sich der schwerpunkt der
bundeswehr auch sehr auf die
auslandseinsätze der kriege in der
ukraine zeigt sind im februar
überdeutlich dass landes- und
bündnisverteidigung wieder der
schwerpunkt der fähigkeiten unserer
streitkräfte sein müssen und der
haushalt 2022 unter sondervermögen
setzen genau hier an wir brauchen wieder
voll und gut ausgestattete einheiten und
verbände damit es in zukunft nicht mehr
notwendig sein wird wie für die
aufstellung des deutschen anteils an der
battle group in litauen die größe eines
verstärkten paar der jungs hat material
und personal aus dutzenden von
standorten und einheiten zusammen zu
ziehen was überall an diesem personal
und material fehlt
angesichts der in vielen bereichen sehr
schwierigen lage der ausrüstung der
bundeswehr sind des herkules aufgaben
die unsere ministerin christine
lambrecht zu bewältigen hat und die zeit
drängt wir brauchen eine sachgerechte
ausstattung und ausrüstung der
bundeswehr und das ist heute noch nicht
zur sprache gekommen eine geeignete
personalstruktur für die streitkräfte
und die optimierung der notwendigen
verfahren rüstungsbeschaffungen und für
das personalmanagement
ganz neu sind diese aufgaben nicht
leider haben sie die vorgängerin der
heutigen ministerin nicht bewältigt die
eine ministerin will er durch die anzahl
der berater im ministerium auch und die
andere wollte sogar noch vor beginn
ihrer amtszeit mit dem wunsch nach
anschaffung eines flugzeugträgers
punkten
besonders erfolgreich weil das nicht
unsere ministerin hingegen hat seit dem
beginn ihrer amtszeit im dezember
bereits die folgenden projekte auf den
weg gebracht
der 35 als nachfolge des tornados das
2,4 millionen und milliarden euro paket
für die persönliche ausstattung der
soldatinnen die bewachung von drohnen
und heute hat ministerin lamprecht
angekündigt welchen schweren
transporthubschrauber die bundeswehr
anschaffen soll mit dem china wird ein
bewährtes system angeschafft und zwar in
übereinstimmung mit dem rad der
militärischen führung und es darf ich an
der stelle auch noch sagen die gesamte
spd-fraktion steht hinter dieser
anschaffung
entgegen mancher pressebericht über
schon wieder kurzfristig r nehmen konnte
wir werden auch insgesamt das
beschaffungswesen modernisieren und
liebe kollegin güllen es geht nicht und
privatisierung es geht um modernisierung
dazu gehört neben dem bereits
vorhandenen eckpunkte programm für
dieses deutsche beschaffungs recht
insbesondere auch die verstärkte
anwendung des artikel ich daran dass 46
absatz 1 buchstabe b das arbeiten des
vertrags über die arbeitsweise der
europäischen union da kann man die
militärische beschaffungen wesentlich
beschleunigen ich habe das selber mal
für ein nato-mitglied getan innerhalb
von drei jahren waren die panzer auf dem
hof und es hat funktioniert
das würde bedeuten dass dringende
beschäftigt schaffung von waffensystemen
ohne förmliches und langwieriges
auswahlverfahren durchgeführt werden ich
darf deshalb an dieser stelle der
ministerin für den einsatz in den ersten
sechs monaten ihrer amtszeit ganz
herzlich danken wir wollen
wir wollen aber auch die sicherheit
haben dass alle die projekte die jetzt
bereits angekündigt sind in einem zug
durch finanziert werden können und zwar
inklusive der notwendigen ersatzteile
und der entsprechenden serviceleistungen
und genau dazu brauchen wir diese
sondervermögen das hoffentlich bis ende
der woche unter dach und fach ist wir
sind auf dem richtigen weg und wir als
spd-fraktion unterstützen deshalb
bundeskanzler olaf scholz und ministerin
christine lambrecht bei der erfüllung
dieser schwierigen aufgaben wir halten
diesen haushalt und das sondervermögen
für eine angemessene reaktion auf die
sicherheitspolitische zeitenwende wir
machen deutschland sicherer vielen dank
für ihre aufmerksamkeit und
für bündnis 90 die grünen hat das wort
die class waagen
ja sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen sehr geehrte
frau bundesministerin sehr geehrte
soldaten soldaten
putins grausamer krieg gegen die ukraine
steht für uns mitglieder des
verteidigungsausschusses ganz oben auf
der agenda auf der tagesordnung wir
wollen und wir müssen der ukraine unsere
bestmögliche unterstützung zukommen
lassen und deshalb ist es mir ein großes
anliegen dass an dieser stelle nochmal
zu betonen die unterstützung der ukraine
muss auch in den kommenden wochen
weiterhin ganz oben auf unserer agenda
stehen wir dürfen uns an diesen krieg
nicht gewöhnen
die zeitenwende
die zeit werde die durch diesen
furchtbaren krieg mitten in europa
eingetreten ist sie ist eine zeitenwende
in der russland politik dieses landes in
der energiepolitik aber eben auch in der
sicherheitspolitik und für uns grüne
steht fest dass wir unsere bündnis und
verteidigungsfähigkeit stärken müssen
dass es keine sache von aufrüstung
sondern von ausrüstung für mich ist klar
eine starke deutsche sicherheits und
verteidigungspolitik kann es nur mit
einer gut ausgestatteten bundeswehr
geben gut ausgestattet und zwar nicht
nur an militärischem gerät sondern auch
an persönliche ausrüstung unserer
soldatinnen und soldaten
dafür bringen wir als ampelkoalition 24
milliarden euro auf den weg
für uns grüne ist
offensichtlich dass sich die ausrüstung
der bundeswehr in einem inakzeptablen
zustand befindet deshalb ist es gut dass
wir zu einer einigung für das
sondervermögen bundeswehr gekommen sind
aber auch in diesem haushalt 22 haben
wir zum beispiel das handgeld für
kommandeure verdoppelt um unbürokratisch
dorthin verantwortung zu schichten wo
akuter bedarf besteht ein thema wo wir
allerdings noch deutlich besser werden
müssen ist eine geschlechterspezifische
schutzausrüstung bislang verfügt die
bundeswehr ja rufen sie nur bislang
verfügt die bundeswehr nicht über
schutzkleidung die speziell an die
weibliche anatomie von soldatinnen
angepasst ist dass die bundeswehr im
gegensatz zu den armeen unserer
partnerländer wie den usa oder
großbritannien noch nicht über solche
kleidung verfügt es verheerend hier
können auch nur wenige zentimeter an
fehlender oder unpassender
schutzkleidung lebensgefährlich für
soldatinnen werden diesen missstand
müssen wir beheben eine
geschlechtergerechte bundeswehr gehört
nämlich auch zur zeitenwende
abschließend möchte ich sagen dieser
haushalt bedeutet einen ersten schritt
in eine gute richtung in eine gute
ausstattung das ist wichtig denn das
wohl unserer soldatinnen soldaten ist
unser aller anliegen sie treten für
unsere demokratie unsere freiheit und
unsere werte mit ihrem leben ein wir
sollten deshalb das bestmögliche tun um
ihre ausstattung ihrer
handlungsfähigkeit und ihre sicherheit
zu gewährleisten
denn ihre sicherheit ist unsere
sicherheit vielen dank und die
soldatinnen hier auf der
zuschauertribüne im plenarsaal die
werden die worte von die klasse wagener
wahrscheinlich ganz gerne gehört haben
zu der
entsprechenden ausrichtung rüstung auch
für frau jetzt marie-agnes
strack-zimmermann die vorsitzende des
verteidigungsausschusses
für die fdp spricht sie
frau präsidentin meine damen und herren
deutschland handelt militärisch seit der
gründung der bürger der bundeswehr
ausschließlich im bündnis unsere
sicherheit basiert auf der unterstützung
unserer partner und in einem bündnis ist
man wohl behütet geht aber genau
deswegen auch verpflichtungen ein
nämlich auch für die sicherheit der
partner verantwortung zu übernehmen und
auf deutschland als starke
volkswirtschaften zu recht innerhalb des
bündnisses große erwartungen ich habe
mit kolleginnen und kollegen an der
parlamentarischen versammlung der nato
in litauen teilgenommen milde
ausgedrückt sind unsere partner spürbar
genervt von uns weil wir diese
erwartungen in deren augen so nicht
erfüllen und unter dem brennglas des
völkerrechtswidrigen russischen
überfalls auf die ukraine wird unser
handeln genau so besonders beobachtet
meine damen und herren angesichts des
morgens verschleppen des vergewaltigungs
und zerstören müssen wir ohne und aber
an der seite der ukraine stehen und die
menschen in der ukraine wollen nicht
hört von uns was nicht geht heute gilt
die richtung vorzugeben organisieren
umsätzen kommunizieren und die
ankündigung des bundeskanzler von der
zeitenwende und die bereitschaft des
finanzministers 100 milliarden euro für
die bundeswehr als sondervermögen
bereitzustellen und unser heutiges
parlamentarisches auf den weg bringen
das ist die historisch und das
historisch richtige signal meine damen
und herren an unsere soldatinnen und
soldaten unsere internationalen partnern
an die bürgerinnen und bürger des landes
dass wir in zukunft eine moderne des
wäre dabei gehört der auftrag der
bundeswehr in den mittelpunkt unserer
entscheidung gestellt die bundeswehr ist
nicht dazu da innen oder
parteipolitische wünsche zu erfüllen die
bundeswehr ist dafür da unsere freiheit
unsere demokratie unsere werte basierte
ordnung wo jeder mensch eben ein wert an
sich ist zu verteidigen und aus diesem
auftrag leitet sich das erforderliche
personal und material ab und dazu
brauchen sie auch einen schlanken
beschaffungsprozess einem modernen
strukturierte bundeswehr und eben einen
entsprechenden wert
meine damen und herren der kampf der
ukraine gegen den russischen überfall
lehrt uns heute eine historische lektion
es gibt keine freiheit ohne mut und
risikobereitschaft und die brutalen
putins dieser erde die brutalen putins
dieser erde schmieren sie sich hinter
ihre ohren müssen wissen dass weder sie
noch die putins es nicht vermögen unsere
freie demokratische welt aus den angeln
zu heben das wird ihnen nicht gelingen
und auch nicht den diktator in dieser
erde und sie sollen alle wissen dass wir
wehrhaft sind übrigens auch hier im
plenum wer bereit und ab sofort auch wir
fähig vielen dank
marie agnes strack zimmermann die
vorsitzende des verteidigungsausschusses
auch sie hatte ja in der vergangenheit
eine schnellere lieferung beispielsweise
auch schwerer waffen gefordert auch
von bundeskanzler urlaub schuss der
heute in seiner rede in der
generaldebatte heute morgen angekündigt
hat drei neue waffen zusagen von
deutschland an die ukraine unter anderem
mehrfach rica raketenwerfer und einem
luftabwehrsystem
in die sachliche debatte ein den ich
erteile zu seiner ersten rede jetzt das
wort doktor marlon
wird für die cdu/csu wird er sprechen
ja sehr geehrte frau präsidentin sehr
geehrte damen und herren die tatsache
dass wir in deutschland das glück haben
seit über 70 jahren in frieden zu leben
verdanken ihr mehreren umständen keinem
aber so sehr wie der mitgliedschaft in
der nato bereits zehn jahre nach ende
des zweiten weltkrieges waren ehemalige
kriegsgegner wie die usa england oder
auch frankreich bereit ausgerechnet
deutschland das so viel grausamkeit und
schrecken über die welt gebracht hatte
bereit in ein gemeinschaftliches
verteidigungsbündnis aufzunehmen das
sollte uns bis heute alle mit
dankbarkeit erfüllen was aber macht
dieses bündnis aus in der nato gilt
einer für alle und alle für einen er ist
dieses gegenseitige versprechen
verbunden mit den militärischen
fähigkeiten aller mitgliedsstaaten
zuvorderst denen der usa macht das
bündnis so besonders stark und hat den
bürgern der nato-mitgliedstaaten diese
lange friedens importe verschafft
selbstredend muss man sich in einem
solchen bündnis vollständig aufeinander
verlassen können
schließlich ist solidarität keine
einbahnstraße
und das geht keinesfalls nur für den
verteidigungsfall sondern in besonderer
weise
zum erhalt des friedens
deutschland hat sich im jahr 2014 in
newport wales im lichte der
völkerrechtswidrigen aktionen der krim
wie alle anderen nato mitgliedsstaaten
auch dazu verpflichtet bis zum jahre 20
24 2 prozent seines
bruttoinlandsproduktes für die
verteidigung auszugeben die
abschlusserklärung von newport trägt die
unterschrift von niemand geringerem als
dem heutigen bundespräsidenten frank
walter steinmeier diese über ein punkt
dienten sicherheitsinteressen des
bündnisses und damit den
sicherheitsinteressen der bundesrepublik
deutschland
amerika england und frankreich zum
beispiel aber auch wirtschaftlich
weniger stärkere länder wie estland
lettland und litauen erfüllen dieses
zwei prozent ziel bereits heute
deutschland leider nicht vor diesem
hintergrund war und bleibt es richtig
dass bundeskanzler scholz am 27 februar
hier im deutschen bundestag angesichts
des russischen angriffskrieges gegen die
ukraine eine zeitenwende ausgerufen hat
diese soll dazu führen endlich unsere
verpflichtung gegenüber unseren nato
partnern vollumfänglich zu erfüllen und
die bundeswehr schnellstmöglich so
auszustatten wie es die landes- und
bündnisverteidigung erfordert
in diesem zusammenhang verwundert ist
allerdings dass sie diesbezüglich
unterstützung des kanzlers durch die cdu
csu fraktion deutlich größer zu sein
scheinen als das in weiten teilen seiner
eigenen koalition der fall ist
ohne die union meine sehr verehrten
damen und herren und das muss man an
dieser stelle noch einmal ganz deutlich
sagen wäre die ausgerufene zeitenwende
eine bloße ankündigung geblieben
und das hat keineswegs nur damit zu tun
dass für eine grundgesetzänderung eine
zweidrittelmehrheit und damit die
stimmen der union erforderlich sind
sondern schlicht damit das wichtige
vertreter der spd diese zeitenwende gar
nicht mittragen oder wie sonst soll man
die jüngsten äußerungen von herrn
mützenich und einigen anderen
prominenten vertretern der spd verstehen
[Applaus]
das darf und soll aber nicht davon
ablenken dass sich die koalition und die
cdu csu fraktion nach intensiven
verhandlungen lässt sich zusammengerauft
haben und ein sehr gutes ergebnis für
die bundeswehr und damit für die
sicherheit deutschlands und europas
erreicht haben zwei verhandlungserfolge
der cdu/csu verdienen dabei besondere
aufmerksamkeit erstens es ist allein
nicht der beharrlichkeit unserer
verhandler zu verdanken dass die 100
milliarden ausschließlich der bundeswehr
zur verfügung stehen werden und zweitens
wir konnten durchsetzen dass die
bundeswehr auch nach dem verzehr der 100
milliarden die erforderlichen
finanziellen mittel erhalten wird die
sie für eine pflichtgemäße erfüllung in
der landes- und bündnisverteidigung
benötigt
[Applaus]
deshalb an dieser stelle noch einmal ein
großes dankeschön an unsere verhandler
von cdu und csu ihr habt sehr wichtig
ist für die bundeswehr erreicht vielen
dank für ihre aufmerksamkeit
malheur für die cdu csu fraktion hat er
gesprochen
seine erste rede wie angekündigt er
kommt aus rheinland pfalz dort direkt
gewählt im wahlkreis in mosel rhein
hunsrück
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin meine
damen und herren gemeinsam mit anderen
kolleginnen und kollegen hier aus dem
deutschen bundestag reich als
stellvertretende delegationsleiterin bei
der parlamentarischen versammlung der
nato in vilnius in litauen am letzten
wochenende auch dort spielte naturgemäß
der brutale angriffskrieg war die mir
putins in der ukraine und gegen die
ukraine eine große rolle er hat
bekanntermaßen unser europa grundlegend
erschüttert unverändert wir alle wir
alle müssen dementsprechend und sein
kompass verändern wir können nicht mehr
so weitermachen wie vor dem 24 februar
in den diskussionen wurde deutlich dass
das alle nato-partner übrigens genauso
sehen und alle ihren beitrag leisten wir
tun das bereits in ruckler im rahmen der
fdp wir werden das auch in zukunft tun
und damit wir das eben wunderbar
hinbekommen damit dass langfristig
funktioniert brauchen wir eine modernere
eine leistungsfähigere bundeswehr denn
nur so kann sie ihren kernauftrag den
kernauftrag der bündnis und
landesverteidigung auch erfüllt
ich glaube uns allen ja auf der
grundsätzliche zustand der bundeswehr
bekannt dass muss ich hier nicht weiter
ausführen aber wichtig ist dass klar ist
dass wir in die ausrüstung in die
ausstattung der bundeswehr investieren
müssen und das werden wir in zwei
bereichen schon einmal hier heute mit
unserem einzelplan mit unseren
verteidigungshaushalt und dann aber auch
mit dem sondervermögen zur stärkung der
bundeswehr die 100 milliarden euro ich
freue mich dass wir diesen weg gemeinsam
gehen auch die kolleginnen und kollegen
von der union wir werden ja heute abend
gemeinsam in den zuständigen ausschüssen
das programm beschließen und dann
hoffentlich auch am freitag hier mit
großer mehrheit im plenum unsere
bundeswehr unterstützen
der verteidigungshaushalt wird im jahr
22 um 35 auf 50,3 milliarden euro
steigen das ist übrigens ein plus von 7%
ich glaube dass eine große leistung auch
unserer fortschritts koalition unserer
ampelkoalition meinen dank an die
haushälterin haushälter von fdp von
grünen aber auch von meiner eigenen
fraktion das ist wichtig und das eine
richtig gute botschaft viele kolleginnen
und kollegen haben schon erläutert in
was wir investieren werden ich
persönlich freue mich auch dass wir 800
m weiter kaufen werden 450 millionen
euro stehen im haushalt als
wahlkreisabgeordnete die nebenan
wunstorf das lufttransportgeschwader 62
beherbergt bin ich dass er glücklich
dass wir gemeinsam diesen schritt gehen
werden liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
um auf die neue realität reagieren zu
können braucht es aber mehr und das habe
ich eben schon gesagt als den reinen
verteidigungshaushalt wir werden diese
sondervermögen gemeinsam angehen und
beschließen diese woche noch ich halte
das für einen zentralen baustein in
unserer stadt souveränität der
staatspolitischen verantwortung aller
fraktionen die das ganze hier ernst
nehmen ich danke unseren bundeskanzlerin
für den impuls er hat die zeitenwende
beschrieben und die 100 milliarden euro
sondervermögen werden ein zentraler
baustein dafür seien gemeinsam hier
verantwortung zu übernehmen wenn die als
demokratinnen und demokraten es ernst
nehmen mit unserer bundeswehr
sollten wir uns nicht nur aus einer
innenpolitischen perspektive tun sondern
eben auch aus einer außenpolitischen bei
der nato tagung haben natürlich
verstärkt zimmermann hat darauf
hingewiesen die andere nato-partner
geschaut was macht eigentlich die
bundesrepublik deutschland und fakt ist
der stellvertretende nato
generalsekretär ghana hat in seiner rede
am plenum am montag nochmal betont und
besonders herausgestrichen dass die
bundesrepublik jetzt diese 100
milliarden euro auf die reise bringen
wird das ist wichtig dieses zeichen auch
in die internationale community liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen ich habe großes
vertrauen dass unser
verteidigungsministerium die ministerin
mit ihrer mannschaft dieses
sondervermögen das geld was
bereitgestellt wird sinnvoll zeitnah und
effektiv einsetzen und verwenden wird
damit wir eben bundeswehr schneller und
besser ausstatten werden ich glaube aber
das ist der letzte punkt ging nochmal
ansprechen möchte dass es nicht nur um
geld gehen darf an dieser stelle und
geld ist wichtig aber
beschaffungsprozesse zu beschleunigen
das ist genauso wichtig und wir erleben
ja schon den ersten gang in die richtige
richtung die ersten
beschleunigungsgesetz sind in der mache
und auch da wünsche ich mir eine große
einigkeit hier im haus dass wir diesen
weg an der stelle auch gemeinsam weiter
gehen werden
und wir haben auch viel personal
gesprochen kolleginnen und kollegen
haben das schon interessiert ich glaube
aber ein weiterer punkt ist auch wichtig
das nennt sich baumaßnahmen
liegenschaftsmanagement wir geben ganz
ganz viel geld in systeme und es ist
richtig und das ist wichtig aber wir
müssen auch schneller sind unsere
kasernen unsere liegenschaften zu
modernisieren zu erweitern da wo das
notwendig ist der bund hatte eine
gewisse verantwortung aber auch unsere
kolleginnen und kollegen in den
bundesländern stich vorbau verwaltung da
müssen wir auch an damit die priorität
der bundeswehr an der stelle auch
berücksichtigung findet um zum schluss
zu kommen kollege
george washington sagte einmal wer auch
den krieg besser vorbereitet ist kann
den frieden am besten waren niemand von
uns hat sich diesen krieg gewünscht
niemand von uns wollte dass wir dieser
bedrohung langfristig ausgesetzt sind
darum müssen wir verteidigung wieder als
zentrale
gesamtgesellschaftliche aufgabe
betrachten eine gut ausgestattete
moderne bundeswehr ist hierfür
unabdingbar die richtigen weichen
stellen die als ampel im rahmen der
zeitenwende nun mit unserem
verteidigungshaushalt und mit dem von
olaf scholz angeschlossenen
sondervermögen herzlichen dank
marja liisa volles war das für die
spd-fraktion und eine rednerin haben wir
noch zu diesem einzelplan das ist die
sprecherin für sicherheit und
friedenspolitik riet der bündnisgrünen
sara nanni
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen meine damen und herren der
brutale russische angriffskrieg gegen
die ukraine er hat uns unermessliches
leid über die menschen in der ukraine
gebracht und er ist auch ein angriff auf
unsere sicherheits ordnung in europa
nato und eu sind dadurch klar heraus
gefordert so stark wie noch nie
politisch aber eben auch militärisch und
für die bundeswehr kommt diese
herausforderung zwar nicht überraschend
aber sie geht doch mit einem gewissen
strecken einher können wir unsere
verpflichtungen im bündnis erfüllen der
neue bedrohungslage auch militärisch
etwas entgegenhalten und die wahrheit
ist hinter uns liegen erst viele jahre
des schlechten schrumpfens und später
des schlechten wachstums sowie eine aus
rüstungspolitik die sich zu viel am
wunsch der wahlkreise einzelner
abgeordneter
orientiert und zu wenig am notwendigen
das muss aufhören
und so haben sie ja das könnte ich mir
bei jeder debatte liebe union auch mit
dafür gesorgt dass wir heute eben nicht
aus voller brust sagen können wir sind
einsatzfähig
das ist bitter und
hergeht sie uns was sie sagen sie machen
solange verteidigungspolitik das heißt
ja nicht unbedingt dass dies gut machen
und es ist eben jetzt die ampel
koalition die sich vorgenommen hat das
zu ändern jetzt steht jetzt auf meinem
zettel ich bin der union dankbar dass
die am freitag das sondervermögen mit
beschließen wird der kollege silber hat
film durch die runde gerufen schauen wir
mal das heißt das was ihr passiert große
reden große rede haben sie gerufen
schauen wir mal große reden aber wenn es
drauf ankommt schauen wir mal doch als
der kollege früheren die rede gehalten
hat und sich bedankt hat dass sie
zustimmen werden haben sie gerufen
schauen wir mal auch der haushalt für
dieses jahr schafft schon die spielräume
die wir dringend brauchen
bündnis heger zu werden die bundeswehr
wird nun finanziell deutlich besser
ausgestattet und daraus erwächst eben
für uns auch eine pflicht besonders gut
mit dem geld umzugehen
ja sie können es nicht glauben ist
trotzdem so besonders hart zu verhandeln
mit der industrie besonders klug und
effizient zu planen und bei der
beschaffung und entwicklung immer auf
europäisch mitzudenken
wir als bündnis grüne werden auch in
zukunft ganz genau hinschauen wir wollen
eine modernere aufgabenorientierte
ausstattung der bundeswehr erreichen und
der
verteidigungshaushalt und auch das
sondervermögen eignen sich eben nicht
für geschenke an die rüstungsindustrie
oder dem wahlkreis
brauchen sie bitte eine frage des kult
eine tops intervention der mann musste
nach ok juli im gegenteil es geht darum
dass diejenigen die für uns eins in
einsätze gehen material wie persönliche
mut ausgestattet sind nicht mehr und
nicht weniger und die bereitschaft genau
dies zu tun die steigt vor zwei wochen
habe ich immer mit einem parteifreund
aus meinem wahlkreis gesprochen ein
ehemaliger soldat
er war lange nicht bei der bundeswehr
und er hat sich jetzt wieder gemeldet
als reservist weil die zeit das
erfordert
zeitenwende das ist nicht nur im
haushalt angekommen zeitenwende das ist
liebe kolleginnen bei ganz vielen leuten
auch persönlich angekommen
dem parteifreund und reservistinnen und
soldatinnen kann ich schon heute
deutlich besser in die augen gucken denn
wir werden die ausdrucks defizite
beseitigen und für den schutz der
soldaten sorgen das ist eine frage der
verantwortung die wir als abgeordnete
tragen und das sind wir unseren
soldatinnen
schuldig
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen wir legen
als fortschritts koalition unseren
ersten gemeinsamen haushalt vor der von
der pandemie bewältigung der klimakrise
und diesem angriffskrieg auf die ukraine
und vielen anderen herausforderung
gleichzeitig geschlagen ist der
verteidigungshaushalt ist gut
ausgestattet und wir tragen hier die
verantwortung und erst recht in
schwierigen zeiten in diesen schwierigen
zeiten deswegen empfehle ich die
zustimmung zu diesem haushalt eine
letzte sache kommen sie bitte zum
schluss nicht bedanke mich bei allen
ampeln partner und ich hoffe dass die
konstruktive zusammenarbeit die wände
ampel dazu hatten auch die union
inspiriert wohl dass sie ihre blockade
bei wirtschaftsplan aufgeben
naja wirtschaftsplan für das 100
milliarden euro sondervermögen wenn sie
es verfolgt haben da geht es ja noch ein
bisschen hin und her eigentlich
grundsätzliche zustimmung eines firma
thomas silberhorn für die union
frau kollegin anni nachdem es für
notwendig befunden haben mich persönlich
zu adressieren
kann sich nur mutmaßen dass sie aus den
reihen der grünen offenbar glauben
wortfetzen von beiträgen zwischen union
und fdp richtig verstanden zu haben
ich will nur für meine person sehr klar
stellen meine zustimmung zu diesem
sondervermögen für die bundeswehr steht
außer frage und ich habe mich in den
letzten wochen sehr intensiv dafür
eingesetzt dass das zustande kommt wir
werden aber auch sehr genau schauen dass
bei der abstimmung die am freitag
hoffentlich ansteht auch aus ihren
reihen der spd und der grünen dafür
einstimmige zustimmung möglich ist
von anni sie haben die möglichkeit zum
antworten
als er sicherlich erreicht das heute
morgen im verteidigungsausschuss die
gelegenheit gewesen wäre sowohl der
grundgesetzänderung der der
grundgesetzänderung von zuzustimmen als
auch hätte es schon eine einigung mit
der union gegeben dementsprechend den
wirtschaftsplan das wurde ob leute runde
sozusagen verhindert da stellt sich
schon ein bisschen die frage warum das
der fall ist es wurde auch offen damit
gedroht dass die zustimmung entzogen
wird und sie haben gerade hier einen
zwischenruf getätigt haben relativ gute
ohren so alt bin ich noch nicht und
haben gesagt schauen wir mal als der
kollege nürnberger sagte dass die union
auch zustimmen wird das habe ich sehr
genau gehört und ich freue mich aber
wenn das anscheinend nicht so gemeint
war und ihre zustimmung der sicher ist
am freitag von den kolleginnen der union
ja diese offene frage waberte immer im
hintergrund bei dieser debatte zum
einzelplan verteidigung sehr wird jetzt
zumindest in zweiter beratung den
aufgerufen und wahrscheinlich
beschlossen beteiligung in der ausschuss
fassung wer stimmt dafür
dass ist die ampel koalition ja stimmt
dagegen
cdu csu auf den die linke enthaltungen
es nicht der fall da ist der einzelplan
angenommen mit 50,4 milliarden euro in
rekordhöhe 70 millionen sondern mal bei
der bereinigungssitzung des
haushaltsausschusses draufgekommen für
bekleidung und für erhalt von flugzeugen
unter anderem ja und diese offene frage
wie gesagt 100 milliarden euro
sondervermögen die union hatte ja dann
gab es eine verhandlungsrunde letzten
sonntag noch immer im finanzministerium
da hatte die union zugestimmt
und die grünen sozusagen sind auch von
ihrer linie da abgerückt das aus den 100
milliarden beispielsweise cyber
sicherheit noch finanziert werden müsste
heute morgen gab es die abstimmung
eigentlich im von haushalts und
verteidigungsausschuss
gestern ist eine wirtschaftsplan
vorgelegt worden also was soll mit den
100 milliarden beschafft werden und die
union sieht da noch gesprächsbedarf die
abstimmung erst mal verschoben im
ausschuss heute abend gibt es sonder
sitzungen der ausschüsse und dann sollte
das ganze am freitag abgestimmt werden
können also das sondervermögen was ja
separat zum haushalt läuft